da bin ich bin echt gespannt morgen mittag kann ich mein neues auto abholen schauen wie das so
ist dann weil es ist ja immer noch was anderes als da ein paar mal um die ecke mit zu fahren
und es dann halt wirklich zu haben ich bin ich bin ich bin ich wirklich mal gespannt wie es im
elektroauto so ist was mir ich habe ein habe es glaube ich sogar noch auf irgendwo den da
das da als vor für auto in grün und den ozean grün was er aussieht wie blau er hat hat freunde
musik ist bisschen laut so anstrengend auch was entspricht
spannenderes haben wir nicht irgendwie hier relaxing das relaxing nintendo irgendwas auch
offen das da ja besser ja also ja das hat noch so schnell geklappt ich hatte glück game up danke
für den sub und hier ist silva kurs auch habe ich oben war noch bevor ich bevor ich setzte dran hatte
ja hat so schnell geklappt und zwar
ich hatte wirklich glück ich habe da einen termin gemacht zum probefahren hier bei mir in der nähe und
die meinten irgendwie ja also sie haben welche bestellt habe ich seit jahren gucken wir doch mal
was von denen die bestellt sind und noch nicht verkauft sind was da am besten passt zu dem was
ich mir so vorstelle ja und am ende habe ich mir gedacht ich habe mir gedacht ich habe mir gedacht
ich habe mir gedacht ich habe mir gedacht ich habe mir gedacht ich habe mir gedacht ich habe mir gedacht
ich habe mich gefragt ich habe mir gedacht ich habe ich mir gedacht ich habe schon schon unfamiliar gemacht
ob dasgresen von da so möchte ich bei mir ist dasStarCenter vor Life auch dasdactypher
was HAk UwU
stimmt
von mirVID
macht ok
dann
richtig
da
dann
möchte ich
werden
und
ja
jetzt
stein
nicht
ist
also
dann
du
kannst
nicht
FDE
am Ende
einufahnden
Und wenn man sich überlegt, was man sich für 25.000 Euro schon für andere fette Autos kaufen kann, muss das sich jetzt im Endeffekt jeder selbst überlegen.
Ja, ich meine, 25.000 Euro ist schon mal eine Hausnummer.
Aber normalerweise kostet es ja noch mehr.
Also normalerweise, wobei das würde ich im Leben nicht ausgeben, ja, im Leben, im Leben nicht.
Ich gebe doch keine 41.000 Euro für so ein kleines, kleines Stadtauto aus.
Da kann es ja noch so viel Elektro sein.
Und, naja, zumindest, ich habe mir so gedacht, wenn wir irgendwie unter 30.000 Euro kommen, denke ich drüber nach.
Es muss auf jeden Fall dieses Jahr sein, damit das mit der Prämie noch klappt.
Und jetzt habe ich ja im Endeffekt 25.200 Euro bezahlt.
Das ist okay.
Das hat auch nicht viele Kilometer gefahren.
Ich meine, das ist vor für Auto da, für, keine Ahnung, für vier, fünf Monate gewesen.
Ja.
Und ich bin echt begeistert.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es so ist.
Ich habe mir das ganze Handbuch schon angeguckt von der Kiste.
Weil du hast ja im Vergleich zu meinem alten, ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier noch offen habe, ja.
Also, guck mal.
So sieht der neue von innen aus im Cockpit.
So sieht das Ding, so sieht der neue aus im Cockpit.
Und so sah mein alter aus im Cockpit.
Haltet euch fest.
High End.
Aber gut, mein altes Auto ist auch 20 Jahre alt.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, das da unten habe ich gar nicht.
Da ist bei mir einfach nichts drinne.
Ich habe nur ein Radio drin.
Den Rest des Zeugs habe ich da gar nicht.
Weißt du, ob man Chrome-Tabs einzeln muten kann?
Also, beim Firefox kannst du hier oben klicken.
Ich glaube, beim Chrome nicht.
Aber was ich mache, ich habe dieses Add-on hier.
Den Volume-Master.
Also, das Ding hat nichts mit dem Coin-Master zu tun.
Da kannst du auch muten.
Einzelne und lauter machen, einzelne Tabs.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, das geht nicht über die Windows-Lautstärke-Regelung,
sondern über den Browser.
Das heißt, mehr als die maximale Lautstärke von Windows kannst du da auch nicht machen,
weil dann hast du eine Übersteuerzeit im Endeffekt.
Geht das mit dem Muten noch?
Zeige ich mal her.
Ach, hier kommt mal hier.
Mute-Zeit funktioniert noch.
Trotzdem finde ich das Add-on wirklich sehr praktisch,
weil du gerade, wenn ich hier für den Stream mal ein bisschen was einstellen muss,
Musik-Lautstärke und so, ist das manchmal nicht genug,
dass du es über den YouTube-Reklamen machst.
Weil der YouTube-Rekler, ja, der hier unten,
der geht ja dank Tablet-Bedienung und allem, was die Seite unterstützt,
mittlerweile nur in kleinen Schritten.
Wieso kein Tesla?
Weil Teslas relativ groß sind und teuer.
Und ich weder 50k plus ausgeben will,
noch ein großes Auto will.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich bin froh, dass das so schnell geklappt hat.
Und ich meine, der Vergleich,
ja, das habe ich mir schon mal angeguckt.
Ich meine, der Vergleich ist schon wirklich offensichtlich, oder?
Das sieht halt aus wie ein Auto vor 20 Jahren.
Und das sieht halt halbwegs modern aus.
Und das ist mehr oder weniger auch genau das Setup, was ich habe,
was man hier sieht.
Also, das hier nicht.
Ich habe keine hier Spezial-Armlehnen mit Gedöns.
Aber hier vorne ist genau das Gleiche.
Klimaanlage, Heizung, Ladeding mit USB-Anschlüssen.
Ja, das hier ist im Endeffekt die Gangschaltung.
Also, also, das ist das, was ich hier sehe.
Also, das ist das, was ich hier sehe.
Parken, rückwärts, Leerlauf, äh...
Ähm, für was steht die?
Ah, Drive, logischerweise.
Das ist was fürs Fahren.
Ja.
Und da saß halt die ganze Krempe hier drauf.
Tja, echt mal gespannt, wie das dann so ist.
Nächstes Auto ist übrigens die Handbremse.
Die ist jetzt einfach nur so ein Knopf,
den du hoch und runter machen kannst.
Das ist Lautstärke für Radio und Telefon.
Und das hier ist Mode Selection
für den...
den...
Wie nennt man das so?
Den Fahrmodus.
Also kannst du ja einstellen, dass das Ding ganz normal fährt.
Also sprich Gaspedal und Bremsen.
Dann kannst du einstellen, dass das Ding automatisch bremst,
wenn du vom Gaspedal runter gehst.
Und dadurch ein bisschen die Batterie auflädt.
Ist ganz praktisch.
Da kannst du theoretisch quasi nur mit einem Pedal fahren.
Gut, manchmal musst du natürlich trotzdem bremsen,
wenn dir die Oma vor's Auto rennt oder so.
Ähm, du kannst mit der Handbremse,
nicht mehr driften.
Das ist...
Das ist richtig.
Das wird wahrscheinlich da weniger funktionieren.
Der macht den...
Der macht den Parkmodus auch automatisch...
Ne, der macht die Handbremse auch automatisch aus,
sobald du Gas drückst.
Also sobald du aufs Gaspedal drückst,
macht er die Handbremse automatisch aus.
Wird das Auto geflasht,
dann das erste, was ich machen werde,
ist das Firmware-Update. Ganz logisch.
Ich hab mich auch schon schlau gemacht,
was Carplay und alles,
was angeht.
Das Ding kann Wireless Carplay.
Das heißt, diesen Navigator da drinnen
werde ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht verwenden,
sondern ich werde im Prinzip zu 90%
übers Handy navigieren.
Einfach, weil das Display...
Ich hab's ausprobiert.
Das Display ist okay.
Das ist jetzt nicht super responsive.
Das ist aber auch nicht, ähm,
laggy as fuck.
Das ist...
Das ist okay.
Das kann man verdienen,
aber ich weiß nicht,
was die Autohersteller machen,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab gehört,
bei Tesla soll das viel geiler sein.
Ähm, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was die Autohersteller machen,
aber diese ganzen eingebauten Entertainment
und, ähm,
Infosysteme, die es da gibt,
die sind alle immer mega
laggy zu bedienen. Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man nicht ein Touchscreen
bauen könnte mit flüssiger Bedienung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob die, ob die wirklich
jeden Cent beim Chip sparen müssen
oder irgendwas einbauen, was 15 Jahre
alt ist oder so, oder ob da jetzt irgendwie
ein 486er drin ist.
Nee, ist es nicht, weil ich irgendeinen Arm,
Low-Power-Arm-Ding, aber trotzdem, ich hab keine Ahnung,
warum die Touchscreens
immer so kacke sind und
die Bedienung von diesen Dingern immer so
lahm ist. In dem Fall, es geht,
also du kannst das, ich weiß nicht, ob man hier ranzoomen kann,
ja, du kannst das ohne Probleme bedienen, aber du merkst
das gerade, wenn du swipes oder wenn du hier die Buttons
drückst, dass es teilweise, du drückst
und dann dauert es halt eine halbe Sekunde.
Was halt,
was halt für ein Arsch ist. Und wo ich mir halt denke,
wenn der Kram, also niemand wird
das hier wahrscheinlich freiwillig bezahlen, aber
die wollen das halt haben.
Empfehlen das zumindest. Und da für
einen laggy Bildschirm, ich mein,
jedes,
sag mal, jedes iPad ist schneller
und das ist mit Sicherheit billiger.
Ähm, und jedes
halbwegs Mittelklasse-Android-Handy ist
deutlich, deutlich, deutlich schneller.
Also keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, was die, was
die da treiben. Aber okay.
Ähm, ja, ich bin,
ich bin wirklich mal
sehr gespannt, wie es ist, dann Elektroauto
zu fahren. Ich weiß gar nicht, was die
einzelnen Knöpfe machen, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich weiß übrigens auch gar nicht, wie man hupt. Wie hupt
man? Das braucht man für Frankfurt. Für Frankfurt ist das wichtig.
Wie hupt man denn? Wahrscheinlich in die Mitte
hauen, oder? Nee.
Weiß gar nicht, wie man hier hupt.
Hab ich noch nicht gebraucht bis jetzt.
Wo hupt man denn hier?
Irgendein Knopf, oder? Nee, hier, hier.
Außen. Hier außen drauf
wahrscheinlich, hä?
Naja.
Hier hast du die erste Freisprechanlage.
Naja, gut.
Alles klar.
Dieses Auto gibt's nächste
Woche. Und mein Agila
hat dann endlich ausgedient.
Der Grüne.
Den muss ich heute Abend noch ausräumen.
Hupe ist Touchscreen,
dritte Menü-Ebene. Das würde mich echt nicht wundern.
Oder ich muss sagen, hey Fiat,
hupt mal, oder so.
Das Ding hat ja angeblich, laut Handbuch,
ich hab's nicht ausprobiert, das Ding hat
ja angeblich Voice,
Voice-Bedienung.
Kannst du hier oben draufdrücken,
oder kannst du ein Code-Wort angeben.
Da kannst du dann sagen, hallo Fiat,
mir ist kalt. Und dann macht er die Heizung an.
Mal gucken,
was es alles für Kommandos gibt.
Ich denke mal, gerade in Kombination,
ich hab mich ja da im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen schlau gemacht,
ich denke mal, gerade in Kombination
mit meinem iPhone und
Shortcuts und
irgendwelchen Carplay-Triggern und
eventuell dann
WLAN-Triggern, so nach dem Motto, wenn man
heimisches WLAN entert, oder wenn
man sich beispielsweise,
wenn irgendeine Message kommt, und wenn
Carplay connectet, könnte ich mir
zum Beispiel ansagen lassen, ob
der Parkplatz vorm Haus frei ist, und solche Sachen.
Also da lässt sich auf jeden Fall mit Carplay
einiges machen.
Was ein bisschen blöd ist,
dass Carplay keinerlei
Video-Output unterstützt.
Ich meine, ich
verstehe es, warum Carplay kein Video-Output
unterstützt. Die wollen nicht, dass die Leute gegen den Baum
fahren, und dann in den Nachrichten kommt,
der Typ hat mit Carplay gerade YouTube-Videos
geguckt, oder Pornhub.
Wie ist klar, warum die das nicht wollen?
Man kann da ein bisschen tricksen mit
Carplay. Du kannst anscheinend dein
iPhone-Bildschirm mirrorn auf dieses
Display, und dann halt alles ausführen,
was du willst.
Wie gesagt, ich will keine Videos
gucken, während der Fahrt, aber zum
Beispiel für Kameras wäre das ganz cool.
Also mal angenommen, ich würde mir
eine Dashcam einbauen, und ich will die
auf dem Display mir angucken, bis ich den
Kamin legt.
Das ist halt kacke, weil das ist laggy as fuck, wenn du es über Screen Mirroring machst.
Wenn du es über Airplay oder sowas casten könntest oder sowas, was es ja nicht kann,
dann wäre es wahrscheinlich deutlich schneller.
Das ist Wireless Carplay.
Der Honda E hat für das Display einen HDMI-Eingang.
Ja, das ist gut. Das ist gut, HDMI-Eingang.
Das ist pogge, weiß ich.
Geht das da auch?
HDMI? Moment, was?
Sekunde.
Was?
HDMI?
Hat das auch? Ich habe kein HDMI gesehen.
Was ist hier mit HDMI?
Hier steht überhaupt nichts von HDMI. Das ist G-Bait.
Das ist Massive G-Bait.
Die Seite.
Ne, das ist der Honda E.
Ne, das hat kein HDMI. Das hätte ich gesehen.
Aber ein HDMI wäre wirklich praktisch.
Ein HDMI wäre wirklich pogge.
Da könnte man einfach die Dashcam irgendwie da einstecken.
Ich sage mal so, normalerweise würde ich mir sowas gar nicht als Auto machen.
Mit meinem alten Auto, weil wenn das kaputt ist, ist es egal.
Aber das neue ist halt ein bisschen teurer.
Ja, also wie gesagt, hat es so schnell geklappt.
Lässt du dir eine Wallbox installieren?
Ja, mache ich.
Wobei ich schon wieder kommen sehe, dass die Elektriker da komische, komische Dinger machen
und ich versuche zu G-Baiten.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was los ist mit Handwerkern.
Es geht jetzt wirklich, muss ich wirklich sagen, nicht.
Auch wenn sich sehr pauschal anhört.
Aber ich wurde in letzter Zeit öfters versucht zu G-Baiten von, von Handwerkern, von Werkstätten,
von allen möglichen, die sich dann immer irgendwelche Dinger ausdecken, warum sie irgendwas, was
ich will, nicht machen können.
Ja, ich habe beim Elektriker angerufen, habe gesagt hier, ich würde gerne eine Wallbox
installieren lassen.
Und da meinten die, das ist ja in nächster Zeit ganz furchtbar schlecht, weil wir haben nur
einen, der das machen kann und der ist jetzt auf der Baustelle und danach ist er im Urlaub.
Und.
Aber.
Vielleicht.
Kann er mal gucken.
Da können wir uns schon was aussuchen.
Und dann meine ich, nee, nee, wir müssen uns nichts aussuchen.
Ich kaufe eine Wallbox und ich baue die Wallbox ein.
Wir müssen uns da nichts aussuchen.
Ich weiß genau, welche ich haben will.
Ja, aber da musste er vorher mal kommen und gucken, ob das auch geht.
Wo ich mir so denke, so Alter, hört auf, mich die ganze Zeit zu verarschen.
Das fragt mich mega ab.
Alle wollen sie dich verarschen und wollen dir irgendwas.
Also ablabern an mehr Kohle.
Ja, ich weiß genau schon, was ich mir für eine Wallbox kaufe.
Und das Ding hat vier Kabel.
Da musste Elektriker das verlängern vom Verteilerkasten, vielleicht ein Zwischenverteiler Ding in Keller
machen und dann das Kabel anschließen.
Fertig.
Das ist das sind nackte Kabel mit ADN Hülsen drauf.
Der muss da.
Also es ist nicht so, als müsste der sich jetzt super, super krasses Zeug.
Das kann jeder.
Da bin ich mir ziemlich.
Es kann jeder Elektriker machen, was ich mir kaufen will.
Ist folgende.
Wie heißt es denn?
Warte mal ADAC Wallbox Test.
Nicht, dass ich allein darauf so viel geben würde, wenn ich nicht noch andere Tests gucke.
Aber ich weiß, die war relativ das Ding, die stand dabei.
Das Teil, das da, mein Hausanschluss macht das.
Wenn mein Hausanschluss die Leistung nicht trägt, dann könnte auch keine andere Wallbox einbauen.
Und es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das hier super krasser Shit.
Ja, das Ding.
Und warum?
Weil es hat zwei Gründe, warum ich mir die kaufen will.
Erstens, weil die relativ günstig ist, weil die in den meisten Reviews und Tests wirklich gut abgeschlossen hat.
Nachteil ist, man findet, man findet im Internet ein paar Benutzerberichte, die sagen, nachts eins, zwei Jahren ist ihnen das Ding durchgebrannt, durchgeschmort, bis er wahrscheinlich zu allen Sachen finden.
Und wer weiß auch, was die Leute damit treiben.
Also hat wirklich gute Reviews, ist relativ günstig und.
Was mir persönlich gut gefällt, ist die Smartphone-Integration.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ihr kennt mich, ihr kennt mich.
Weniger die Smartphone-Integration.
Was ich persönlich äußerst ansprechend finde, ist, dass die, nicht Home Assistant, die haben, und das machen wenige Hersteller.
Ihr wisst, wie es ist.
Ja, das hört sich jetzt fast an wie das Video vom Assi-Tony.
Ich erzähl nix, oder nee, was hat er, was hat er gesagt?
Ihr wisst, wie es ist, ihr wisst, wie es ist, ja.
Also Leute, ihr wisst, wie es ist.
Das machen wenig Hersteller.
Ja, die haben eine MQTT- und HTTP-API.
Standardmäßig drinne.
Zeigt mir mal einen Hersteller, der sein Gerät nicht verrammelt bis sonst was und offiziell offene APIs anbietet.
Das kannst du vergessen, das macht keiner.
Die haben sogar API-Docs auf GitHub.
Das muss man sich mal überlegen, guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, Cloud-API braucht man nicht, ja.
Aber du kannst, du kannst, wie gesagt, eigene MQTT-Server hier zum Beispiel.
Ja, da war's.
Eigene MQTT-Server.
Ab 4. Version ist es möglich, einen eigenen MQTT-Server zusätzlich zur Go-E-Cloud zu, ja, ich will die, die, die Go-E-Cloud werde ich eh nicht verwenden.
Das ist, das ist, das ist richtig nice, ja.
Und dementsprechend gibt es dafür selbstverständlich schon Home Assistant Integrations, die dann zum Beispiel so aussehen.
Weiß nicht, warum es da zwei verschiedene gibt, aber, ja, die sehen dann so aus.
Guck, da hast du direkt den Home Assistant.
Hast du dann deine, ähm, deinen Charger.
Du kannst auswählen, ähm, an, aus.
Du kannst das Ganze limitieren, wenn du den Akku nicht voll machen willst.
Oder wenn du sagst, hey, äh, ich will gleich losfahren, ich mach jetzt aus oder was auch immer.
Weil der Fiat, die Fiat-Firmware ist ja ein bisschen fail, was das angeht.
Also in, also, mein neues Auto ist nicht in der Lage, über die App das Laden an- und auszuschalten, was auch relativ firmenverbrannt ist.
Du kannst bloß sagen, maximal 80%.
Laden oder so, aber du kannst nicht sagen, jetzt laden an- und aus.
Dann mach ich's halt über die Wallbox.
Äh, du kannst die Temperatur dir anzeigen lassen.
Du kannst dir monatliche Zusammenfassungen anzeigen, was du denn alles gechargt hast.
Dann kannst du dir daraus ausrechnen lassen, was hat das gekostet.
Wenn ich nächstes Jahr mir das dann mal mit, ähm, Solarpanels angucke.
Wann, wann ist Fantreffen?
Bei einer Million Abos, wenn ich auch Face-Reveal mache.
Komm, lass dann alles.
Ja, beim Italien.
Auf dem Buchberg, genau.
Da, wo jetzt die Pizza 19 Euro kostet.
Das ist mega teuer, Alter.
Ja, ähm, was, was wollte ich grad sagen?
Genau, kannst du jetzt ausrechnen lassen.
Nächstes Jahr, wenn ich mir das dann mal mit Solarpanels auf dem Dach angucke.
Und mit, mit eigenem Akku und, und, und solchen Geschichten.
Das mach ich aber erst nächstes Jahr.
Dieses Jahr wird das nichts mehr.
Und, ähm, dann auch noch ein paar andere Räume mit, mit, äh, Split-Innengeräte für die Klimaanlage, Ausrüst und sowas.
Dann kann man das richtig gut ausrechnen.
Dann kann ich dann auch sehen, okay, wie viel hab ich gechargt, wie viel hab ich jetzt dadurch quasi gespart,
beziehungsweise wie viel hab ich davon aus dem Akku oder beziehungsweise halt aus der, äh, aus den Solarpanels gezogen.
Das ist richtig nice.
Also, dass man das ordentlich auslesen kann, ist für mich ein riesen Pluspunkt.
Und das in Kombination.
Wie viel Ampere?
Äh, 16.
Also, die gibt's in 16 und 32.
Dementsprechend kommst du am Ende halt auf...
Auf 11 Kilowatt, beziehungsweise mit der 32 auf 22.
Ich hab mich auch erst gefragt, wie das geht.
Ich erklär euch das mal kurz.
Pass.
Max Elektrikors am Start.
Max, Max, Max, Max Elektrikors am Start.
Also, wie kommt man auf 11 Kilowatt?
Also, normalerweise...
Und jetzt, bevor ihr sagt, das ist Mist, was ich erzähle, warte erstmal, bis ich fertig bin.
Normalerweise kriegst du aus einer Steckdose maximal...
Das da raus.
230, äh, 230 Volt.
Und 16 Ampere.
Also, sprich, wenn wir jetzt mal alles weglassen, kriegst du 3,6 Kilowatt oder 3,7 Kilowatt raus.
Was du allerdings auch nicht dauerbelasten kannst.
Also, mal angenommen, du hast eine 16 Ampere Sicherung dran.
Ich weiß, es gibt ja genug Steckdosen, die haben sogar nur eine 10 Ampere Sicherung dran.
Aber, mal angenommen, du hast das.
Das ist das Maximale, was du aus einer normalen Steckdose rausholen kannst.
Das da.
Realistischer betrachtet ist es wahrscheinlich eher sowas, wenn du nicht willst,
dass es überhitzt oder so.
Jetzt, bei den Dingern ist das anders.
Die werden ja nicht angeschlossen an eine normale Steckdose,
sondern die werden entweder angeschlossen an...
Die werden entweder angeschlossen an so eine...
Wie heißt das Ding?
Das, was Beiß sagt.
Diese rote.
Oder aber direkt mit Kabeln vom Elektriker an irgendeinen Verteiler.
Ne, damit fang ich nicht an, Kami, weil ich da keine Ahnung hab.
Ja?
Man muss übrigens die Fix-Variante verwenden, falls man irgendwo Fördergelder beantragen will.
Es gibt zwar keine Bundes...
Leute, ich sag euch, diese ganze Fördergeld-Thematik bei Elektroautos ist unglaublich kompliziert.
Ich blick da jetzt auch nur jetzt durch, weil ich mir gekauft hab und danach nie wieder.
Also bundesweite Förderung für Wallboxen oder Charger daheim gibt es nicht mehr.
Gab es letztes Jahr noch, gibt es nicht mehr.
Ist ausgelaufen, sind die Fördermittel erschöpft.
Aber es gibt oftmals...
Es gibt oftmals noch Förderprogramme, entweder von Ländern oder manchmal auch von der jeweiligen Stadt, wo man wohnt.
Und da müsst ihr gucken.
Aber was alle Förderprogramme gemein haben, ist, dass du einen fest installierten Charger brauchst.
Zu 99%.
Ja, Förderungen werden jedes Jahr schlechter.
Dieses Jahr ist die Förderung für Autos noch gut, die Förderung für Charger gibt es nicht mehr.
Also du brauchst einen fest installierten Charger für 99% aller Förderungsregeln.
Der muss fest installiert sein.
Und du darfst keinen Charger nehmen, den du theoretisch abmachen kannst.
Warum? Wer sich das ausgedacht hat, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber nimmst du den hier, kannst du keine Förderung beantragen, falls du Förderung beantragen kannst.
Nimmst du den hier und lässt dir den vom Elektriker anschließen, kannst du Förderung beantragen, wenn es das bei dir gibt.
Also, der hier hat diesen Anschluss.
So, und im Endeffekt, alles, was der Elektriker machen muss, ist das Anschließen.
Weiß nicht, ob man hier ordentliche Bilder nochmal hat.
Ja.
Das ist, das ist der...
Alter, das mussten die auch jetzt erst einblenden, ne?
So.
Hat man da mal irgendwie ordentliche Bilder von?
Ne, natürlich, natürlich nicht.
Ja doch, hier, hier, schlecht ausgeschnittenes GIF.
Ob man das hier irgendwo sieht.
Ah, da hat man es gesehen, guckt.
Das muss der Elektriker anschließen.
Und ganz im Ernst, das sind vier Adern.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die dran müssen, ist aber nicht mein Problem.
Der Elektriker weiß das schon.
Schon fix und fertig mit Adern, Endhülsen drauf und alles.
Also, im Prinzip muss der eigentlich nur vom Anschluss im Keller das verlängern.
Irgendeinen Zwischenverteiler oder wie man das nennt, irgendeine Zwischenbox setzen.
Dort das miteinander verbinden und fertig.
Also, das sollte, würde ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten, jeder Elektriker hinkriegen,
ob der sich jetzt auf Wallboxen spezialisiert hat oder nicht.
Was mir meiner erzählen wollte.
Und.
Deswegen fand ich es halt kacke, dass ich da wieder so, dass sie wieder versucht haben, mich so zu gebeten.
So mit, ah, ob das geht und ah, da müssen wir gucken.
Nein, natürlich geht das.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob wir elektrisch bewandte Leute, Plusguy könnte, könnte sein.
So aus den Chatnachrichten, bewandte, bewandte Leute im Chat haben.
Also, das muss doch jeder Elektriker hinkriegen, mir sowas anzuschließen.
Das ist, das ist so, wie wenn ich, wie wenn ich sagen würde, kannst du mir, kannst du mir eine SATA-Festplatte anschließen oder so.
Sag ich, ja, auch, mach auf.
Mach auf und ich stöpsel an, ja.
Ich glaube, die wollten mich schlicht und ergreifend gebeten.
So, ach ja, ich wollte euch ja erklären, wie man auf 11, 11 Kilowatt kommt.
Also, das liegt daran, normale Steckdose, sag mal, realistisch unter Dauerbelastung eher sowas.
So 2,8 Kilowatt oder 2800.
Allerdings, das hier, diese Dinger sind ja 400 Volt und 16 Ampere.
Und da werdet ihr feststellen, das reicht immer noch nicht.
Das sind immer nur 6,4 Kilowatt.
Aber, aber, jetzt, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's.
Man muss das irgendwie mal 1,5 hoch 2 oder ähnlich, ich war, ich, ich kann, ich kann die Formel nicht, ne, nicht mal 3, nicht mal, es ist nicht mal 3.
Es ist nicht mal 3, es ist irgendwie mal 1,5 hoch 2, irgendwie so ganz komische Formel, fragt mich jetzt nicht.
Oder Wurzel, ist es Wurzel 3?
Kann auch sein.
Ne, mal Wurzel aus 3.
Okay.
Mal, mal Wurzel aus 3.
Exzellent, genau das.
Wie komme ich auf mal 1,5 hoch 2?
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich weiß, irgendwo habe ich, habe ich gestern.
So, also so, so geht das und dann kommt man auf, auf 11.000, war doch 11 Kilo, äh, ja, 11.000.
11.585,1,2,5,1,6,8,4.
Kommt man an, so und deswegen sind das 11.
11, haben die Dinger maximale Leistung 11, 11 Kilowatt.
Weil, weil 400 Volt, 16 Ampere und das Ganze dann irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, warum Wurzel 3, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil drei Phasen oder so und ich habe aber keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet, beziehungsweise was es für Auswirkungen hat, weil ich kein Elektriker bin.
Dafür braucht man eine extra Genehmigung.
Nein, du brauchst keine extra Genehmigung, du musst nur Bescheid sagen, dass du eine hast.
Bei 22 Kilowatt brauchst du eine extra Genehmigung, bei 11 nicht.
Und ich habe das mal ausgerechnet, das ist okay.
Äh, mein Fiat 500e hat eine, hat glaube ich eine 42 Kilowattstunden Batterie.
Ja, und das kann man jetzt ja über den Daumen gepeilt ausrechnen.
Und nein, wir, wir rechnen da jetzt nicht ein, äh, was du vielleicht noch an Verlusten hast beim Laden, was da an Wärme verloren geht und hast du nicht gesehen.
Sondern wir, wir machen das jetzt wirklich.
Wir machen das jetzt wirklich, richtig, richtig nubisch.
Wo habe ich denn jetzt hier mein Kram ausgerechnet?
Ja.
Okay, wie war das nochmal?
Mal Wurzel 3.
Five-Header-Time vom Chat wieder.
Ähm, nur mal so ganz, ganz grob über den Daumen gepeilt.
So.
Also, wenn du da, wenn das Ding 11 Kilowatt Leistung, äh, ja, rausbekommt.
Also, Watt ist ja quasi Energie pro Zeit schon.
Deswegen macht es ja auch immer keinen Sinn zu sagen.
Es sind, was manche Leute machen, es ist so, Watt pro Sekunde oder so, es ergibt keinen Sinn.
Also, Watt ist ja schon Energie pro Sekunde.
Ursprünglich waren es mal Joules, Joules pro Sekunde.
Und, ähm, also kannst du im Endeffekt, und das hier ist auch, und das muss man vielleicht auch nochmal dabei sagen, weil das auch einige Leute verwirrt.
Der Unterschied zwischen Kilowattstunden und Kilometer pro Stunde, auch wenn man das vielleicht ähnlich ausspricht, ist was komplett anderes.
Das ist, das eine ist Kilowattstunde.
Kilometer durch die Zeit.
Und das hier ist Kilowatt mal Zeit.
Also, das hier ist eine Menge.
Und dementsprechend macht es auch Sinn, dass du Batterien oder, oder, oder Akkus in Kilowattstunden angibst.
Weil, das heißt, im Endeffekt einfach was reinpasst.
Also, die Energiemenge, die das speichern kann.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun, wie lang du da was rausziehen kannst.
Wie lang hängt dann davon ab, ja, wie viel Leistung denn du brauchst aus der Batterie.
Ähm, das ist die Menge, das ist die Energiemenge.
Die Energiemenge, die reinpasst.
Ein Herd hat auch einen 400 Volt Anschluss, ja.
Meistens. Das ist dann auch so ein rotes, rotes Ding.
Genau, und das heißt, man kann das jetzt relativ einfach rechnen, wenn man es nicht so genau machen will.
Kannst du theoretisch sagen, okay, ähm, wie lang brauche ich, um das aufzuladen?
Naja, vier Stunden ungefähr.
Wenn man sagt, man hat noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen Verlust und sonst was.
Dreieinhalb, vier Stunden oder so.
Müsste das dauern, aufzuladen, ungefähr.
Allerdings, lädst du ja meistens nicht von 0 auf 100 auf, sondern du lädst von, ich weiß nicht, von 30 auf 80 oder so.
Also, ich würde mal sagen, wahrscheinlich ist das Ding in zweieinhalb Stunden wieder einsatzbereit, wenn man das damit auflädt.
Was auch für mich der Grund ist, weil der Fiat hat jetzt ja keine super Riesenbatterie.
Ist auch ein kleines Auto.
Ähm, zweieinhalb Stunden irgendwie braucht das dann zum Aufladen.
Deswegen nehme ich auch die 11 Kilowatt Variante und nicht die 22.
Das reicht.
Ganz ehrlich, in zweieinhalb Stunden wieder aufgeladen ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, du hast recht.
Wird es wahrscheinlich nicht, wie gesagt.
Das ist auch nur ganz grob gerechnet.
Ähm, der Akku lädt ja nicht immer gleich schnell.
Aber so über den Daumen gepeilt.
Über den Daumen gepeilt ist das Ding zumindest in zweieinhalb Stunden kannst du damit wieder fahren zum Einkaufen und alles.
Und auch ein bisschen weiter.
Das ist okay.
Du kannst den Charger in der Küche.
Anschließen.
Nee, da ist mein Herd dran.
Ich meine, ich will nicht mein Herd abziehen, um den Charger anzuschließen.
Das wäre irgendwie ein bisschen.
So, so sieht es aus.
Also, das Ding will ich eingebaut haben.
Das Ding will ich eingebaut haben.
Und wie gesagt, das müsste jeder Elektriker hinkriegen.
Und mich ärgert es einfach, dass ich schon wieder versucht werde zu Cheatbaiten.
Mit irgendwie, ja, ob das dann geht.
Und ach, ob das dann der Charger.
Das ist alles Blödsinn.
Also mal ganz im Ernst.
Das kriegt jeder Elektriker angeschlossen.
So wie jeder, der ein bisschen IT-technisch was, keine SATA-Platte anschließen kann.
Ich glaube, ein großer Unterschied ist das nicht.
Ich meine, das sind vier Kabel, die an die richtigen Stellen müssen.
Vielleicht musst du es nochmal verlängern.
Ein bisschen.
Das kriegt jeder Elektriker hin.
100 Pro.
Das wage ich einschätzen zu können als Nicht-Elektriker, dass das jeder Elektriker hinkriegt.
Die Leute am Telefon haben doch auch keine Ahnung.
Ja gut, dann sollen sie aber nicht so tun.
Als hätten sie Ahnung, beziehungsweise mich Cheatbaiten.
Dann sollen sie es halt sagen, dass sie keine Ahnung haben.
Gut.
So, also so sieht es aus.
Gab es sonst noch irgendwelche Questions?
Go Wizard, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, bis ich die Wallbox dran habe, mache ich es halt mit dem normalen Ladekabel.
Was dabei ist.
Das lädt dann aber halt richtig lang.
Topics, danke für den Sub.
Das hatten wir schon.
Das hatten wir auch schon.
Ja, damit habe ich mich auch schon beschäftigt.
Das ist diese Zertifikatsgeschichte, dass du quasi dein CO2, was du sparst, verkaufen kannst an irgendwelche Unternehmen, die gerne die Umwelt verschmutzen.
Und dann kriegst du ein bisschen Kohle für.
Eigentlich Pfeifert-Idee.
Das geht ja erst seit diesem Jahr oder seit letztem Jahr für Privatpersonen.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Wenn man es denn schon hat.
Dann ist zumindest Wartungsarbeiten und so quasi hat sie schon bezahlt.
So.
Ja, weil es ein bisschen teuer ist.
Und es sich für meine Fahr...
Wie nennt man das?
Fahrcharakteristik?
Nee.
Also für meine Fahrgewohnheiten.
Fahrgewohnheiten.
Überhaupt nicht eignet.
Geschweige denn, dass es in Parkplätze gescheit passt und so.
Nee, nee.
Das Auto ist schon genau richtig für mich.
Hast du schon die APIs vom Auto gecheckt?
Ja, hab ich.
Uconnect hat keine offiziellen API-Docs.
Aber Uconnect hat eine Webseite.
Offizielle API-Docs gibt es natürlich nicht.
Aber es gibt eine Webseite, über die man alles machen kann.
Und wenn es eine Webseite gibt, dann wisst ihr genauso gut wie ich.
Entweder parse ich die Webseite oder mache einen Headless-Chrome.
Oder aber ich gucke in den Developer-Tools, was die eigentlich zu ihrem Server schicken.
Okay.
Also wenn es noch keine Fiat Uconnect-Integration für Home Assistant gibt, dann baue ich eine.
Und dann habe ich mein Auto im Home Assistant drin.
Dann habe ich meine Wallbox, meinen Charger in Home Assistant drin.
Und dann kann ich alles Mögliche automatisieren, was ich will.
Vor allem in Kombination mit Carplay kann man dann wahrscheinlich richtig coole Sachen machen.
So nach dem Motto, wenn Carplay connected ist und ich im WLAN zu Hause bin,
dann, was weiß ich, vielleicht lasse ich mir irgendwann mal ein automatisches Tür- oder Garagentor oder was auch immer Öffnereien machen.
Dann kann ich das damit auslösen.
Oder ich kann mir ansagen lassen, wenn ich den, was ich auch machen könnte zum Beispiel, ja.
Das erste, was mir einfällt, ich komme da bestimmt noch auf bessere Ideen, ja.
Zum Beispiel, ich setze mich, ich habe gecharged, ich setze mich ins Auto, schmeiße mein Handy in die Ladeschale, sprich Carplay connected.
Dann sagt er mir an, was weiß ich, wie viel das letzte Aufladen gekostet hat oder so.
Oder wie lange er gebraucht hat oder irgendwas, ja.
Irgendwie kannst du super darauf reagieren.
Das ist eigentlich eine coole Geschichte.
Und wenn beides drin ist, habe ich auch Zugriff eben auf die Daten aus Uconnect und von meinem Aufladegerät.
Also da kann man sicherlich coole Sachen machen.
Ich könnte sogar solche Dinge machen, wie das...
Mein Handy überträgt ja, wo ich bin, an meinen Home Assistant.
Und ich könnte zum Beispiel solche Dinge machen, wie, wenn ich auf dem Weg nach Hause bin, dann...
Und Carplay connected ist, weil ansonsten bin ich im Zug, da interessiert mich das nicht.
Also quasi, wenn meine Travel Direction im Home Assistant towards Home ist und Carplay connected ist,
dann schickt es mir eine Nachricht, ob der Parkplatz vom Haus frei ist.
Ansonsten weiß ich, ob ich...
...aufmachen muss, auf den Parkplatz fahren muss oder direkt vor das Haus fahren kann und sowas.
Da kann man richtig coole Automatisierungen machen.
Da muss ich in Zukunft mal gucken, was man da so alles Schönes, Schönes treiben kann.
Für was steht das U? Keine Ahnung.
Für Fiat? Für Ubisoft?
Oh ja, hoffentlich haben die...
Ich hoffe ja nicht, dass Ubisoft was mit meiner Autobedienung zu tun hat.
Nö, habe ich nicht. Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Wo hat man denn sowas normalerweise?
Außer in der Küche für einen Herd.
Also ist mir nicht...
...bewusst, dass ich sowas habe.
In der Garage?
Meine Garage hat keinen Stromanschluss.
Garage ist reines Abstellding.
Bisher gewesen.
Vielleicht bekommt die ja in Zukunft noch einen.
Die Werkstatt hinten vielleicht.
Aber die Werkstatt hinten hat auch nur eine ganz normale 230 Volt Schuko-Steckdose.
Bisschen laut, hä?
Was hatten wir alles schon?
Der Guido, danke für den Sub.
Massive Subscriptions hier wieder.
Danke an alle, die ich übersehen habe.
Die auch, so wie es mein ehemaliger Englischlehrer an der Berufsschule gesagt hat,
subscribiert haben.
Habe ich euch das jemals erzählt?
Ich glaube schon.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Recycle Story hoch 10.
Das habe ich bestimmt schon 20 Mal erzählt.
Ja, ich habe meinen Berufsschullehrer gefragt, was Subscriben auf Deutsch heißt.
Und dann meinte er subscribieren.
Habe ich mir auch gerade alles klar.
Subscribieren.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ja, warum?
Leute, ich weiß nicht, was diese Fragen, also was genau wollt ihr wissen?
Ich wurde jetzt schon gefragt, warum kein Tesla?
Warum kein Porsche?
Warum kein E-Smart?
Das kannst du weiterführen mit jedem Autotyp, mit jeder Automarke, mit jedem Autohersteller.
Warum kein Fahrrad?
Warum keine Inlineskates?
Oder kein Longboard?
Wobei Longboard ist, glaube ich, überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt.
Warum kein Roller?
Warum kein privater Helikopter?
Ja, kann ja alles heutzutage.
Kannst du auch an der normalen Steckdose laden mit dem, was für einem Booster?
An der normalen Steckdose laden ist halt langsam.
Der Booster kann noch so viel boosten.
Mehr als 230 Volt mal 16 Ampere maximal wird das da nicht rauskriegen, weil woher soll der was boosten?
Eigener Zug, ja, das wäre es noch.
Und wie gesagt, Dauerbelastung, Dauerbelastung 16 Ampere an der normalen Steckdose will man oder sollte man gar nicht machen.
Topics, danke für den Sub.
Nee, habe ich schon gesehen, aber trotzdem, bock.
Ja, nächstes Jahr aber erst.
Und ich weiß noch nicht, ob das wirklich dazu kommen wird.
Also ich habe für nächstes Jahr geplant, also ein bisschen geguckt habe ich dieses Jahr schon.
Ich weiß beispielsweise auch, in welche Richtung.
Ich hatte letztens, ich weiß, ich hätte es euch gezeigt, also nicht bei meinem Haus, sondern bei einem anderen Haus.
Ich weiß die Seite nicht mehr.
Ich habe letztens so eine Seite gehabt, da konnte man den Sonnenstand für verschiedene Richtungen auf Häuserdächern sich anzeigen lassen.
Und ausrechnen lassen, wie viel Quadratmeter Solarpanels ungefähr was bringen.
Das konnte man auf so einer Map, konnte man quasi dann einzeichnen.
Und er hat dann geguckt, wie ist der Sonnenstand das Jahr über so.
Und da habe ich mir das mal angeguckt.
Das heißt, ich weiß, in welche Richtung das gehen muss, die Solarpanels bei mir auf dem Haus.
Und wo man theoretisch was machen könnte.
Also wenn ich es ganz extrem übertreibe, was ich nicht machen werde, das was ich nicht machen werde, weil mir das viel zu teuer ist.
Also ich könnte auf der einen Dachhälfte was machen.
Also ich habe ja kein flaches Dach, ich habe ja so ein, wie nennt man das, so ein normales Dach.
So ein Häuschendach halt, kein flaches Dach.
Wie nennt man das? Spitzes Dach?
Wie heißt denn da ein normales Dach?
Giebeldach.
Mr. Spielunkel weiß Bescheid.
Saffeldach.
So immer.
So ein normales Dach halt.
Also das heißt, ich könnte es nur sinnvoll auf einer Seite machen vom Dach.
Aber was ich machen könnte.
Ich könnte es auf dem Stall gegenüber halbwegs sinnvoll machen.
Und ich könnte es theoretisch auch noch auf der Garage halbwegs sinnvoll machen.
Weil das alles in die Richtung geht und da keine Schatten davor sind großartig.
Aber da bezahle ich mich dumm und dämlich.
Was ich machen werde ist wahrscheinlich erstmal auf der einen Dachhälfte.
Und dann muss ich noch gucken mit welchem Akku und wie das.
Da muss ich mich wirklich im Detail mit beschäftigen, dass ich da genau durch bin.
Weil ansonsten, wenn du da, also eins kann ich euch jetzt aus dieser Erfahrung schon wieder sagen.
Ja, was Elektroauto angeht.
Wenn ihr selbst euch nicht damit beschäftigt, ihr werdet an allen Stellen gebatet und beschissen.
Wirklich.
Das mit dem Elektriker war wieder so der Tropfen auf, nee, wie so das Fass zum Überlaufen gebracht hat.
An jeder Stelle, wenn du nicht genau weißt, was Sache ist, du wirst gebatet.
An jeder Ecke erzählen die dir irgendwas.
Was ja sinnvoll klingt, wenn man es selbst nicht weiß.
Und dann im Endeffekt bezahlst du dann tausende Euro mehr.
Als sein müsste.
Also man muss sich mit, gerade mit so teuren Sachen, muss man sich vorher einfach beschäftigen.
Und selbst ein bisschen Durchblick haben, dass die einen nicht so sehr gebaten können.
Ja, und das gucke ich mir nächstes Jahr an.
Und in Kombination, in Kombination mit der Solaranlage auf dem, also mit dem, mit der Photovoltaik nennt man es ja.
Anlage auf dem Dach, werde ich dann auch mal gucken, ob ich noch mehr Räume innen drinne anschließen lasse an meine Klimaanlage.
Aktuell hat die Klimaanlage ja nur zwei Räume, mein Arbeitszimmer und mein Schlafzimmer.
Das ist so eine Split-Klimaanlage, so mit dem Außengerät und Innengerät.
Und die kann, soweit ich weiß, fünf Innengeräte, von denen irgendwie, glaube ich, nur zwei standardmäßig gleichzeitig an sein können.
Aber das reicht ja.
Und ich, ich möchte noch andere.
Ich will beispielsweise das Wohnzimmer noch, Schlafzimmer unten noch.
Und ja, mal gucken, auch noch, auch noch da anschließen.
Weil dann habe ich die Möglichkeit, komplett zu heizen und zu kühlen mit dem Ding.
Weil Gasheizung, ihr wisst, ich habe eine Gasheizung.
Wer weiß, was Gas in zwei, drei Jahren kostet.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich, zumindest ist es nicht gut, es ist auf jeden Fall gut, wenn man Alternativen hat.
Und zumal das Ding kühlen und heizen kann, ist ja da auch nichts verschenkt.
Weil kühlen wirst du im Sommer in Zukunft definitiv mehr brauchen.
So, und dann werde ich das soweit im Haus installieren lassen.
Die Räume bieten sich halt an, weil da muss ich nicht großartig Röhren durch Räume legen.
Und dann habe ich die Möglichkeit, quasi mit Strom zu kühlen und zu heizen.
Und das in Kombination mit, mit ein paar Solarpanels und einem Akku.
Dann kann ich theoretisch quasi meinen eigenen Strom verheizen und verkühlen.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einem Sonnenkollektor und einem Solarpanel?
Ah ne, Sonnenkollektor ist das, was dein Wasser warm macht, oder?
Oh, da musst du ja Wasser, da musst du ja Rohre und so noch aufs Dach legen.
Ich glaube, das wird dann ultra teuer.
Warum kein Teleporter? Ganz ehrlich, sobald es Private Teleporter gibt, da bin ich sofort dabei.
Wobei, ne, da bin ich nicht sofort dabei.
Weil ihr wisst ja, was Teleporter machen, ne?
Es ist nicht so, dass Teleporter euch von A nach B transportieren.
Teleporter zerstören euch an A und erstellen euch neu an B.
Das heißt, ihr sterbt an A und ihr werdet neu mit einem 3D Drucker quasi zusammengesetzt an B.
Das ist eigentlich was total abartiges, wenn man sich überlegt, Teleporter.
Und was passiert, wenn der Teleporter euch an A nicht zerstört? Dann gibt's euch auf einmal zweimal.
Also sobald du Teleporter hast, kannst du auch Leute eins zu eins klonen.
Also das ist... Teleporter hört sich cool an, aber wenn man sich mal so ein bisschen überlegt, was es eigentlich heißt, sich teleportieren zu lassen, ist es eine ziemlich eklige und fragwürdige Angelegenheit.
Und vor allem, was passiert, wenn er ein paar Sachen nicht richtig zusammensetzt?
Also ich würde auf jeden Fall ein paar Teleporter-Generationen abwarten, bevor ich mir sowas hole.
Weil ich meine, ist ja logisch, ne?
Ihr müsst quasi, nennen wir es mal, komplett alle Informationen, die man braucht, um euch wieder aufbauen zu können, müssen quasi an der Quelle eingelesen werden.
Inklusive quasi eurem letzten Hirnsnapshot.
Also komplett den Aufbau, alle Informationen, die man braucht.
Dann werdet ihr desintegriert.
Ihr werdet quasi...
Ihr löst euch quasi auf an Punkt A.
Dann werden alle Informationen, die man dazu braucht, um euch zu rekonstruieren, übertragen.
Maximal mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit, logischerweise.
Werdet dann empfangen an B.
Und dann werdet ihr dort mit irgendeinem 3D-Drucker oder was auch immer rekonstruiert.
Also sprich, seid ihr überhaupt noch der Gleiche nach dem Teleport?
Ist denn vielleicht irgendwas anders, ja?
Und stellt euch mal wirklich vor, dass ihr seid dann nicht wirklich weg an A und es gibt euch beide.
Also das... Teleport ist wirklich fragwürdige Geschichte.
Ne, noch nicht. Wer weiß.
Aber ihr kennt mich, ich trink eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts.
Das einzige Mal, wenn ich was trinke, ist vielleicht bisschen was an Weihnachten oder Silvester.
Und da eigentlich auch kaum was.
Ja, es ist mega teuer. Es ist mega teuer.
Moment, Strom... 73 Cent?
Da kann ich ja schneller bei uns am Charger, da kann ich ja billiger am Charger in der Stadt tanken, als bei mir daheim.
Muss mal kurz gucken. Strompreise.
Zeig mal her. Hanau. Gibt's da irgendwie... Kosten das?
Äh, das kann's nicht sein.
Hier, 29 Cent. 29 Cent.
Das ist aber ganz schön viel, das ist jetzt dreifache.
Strompreis.
Was? Check 24. Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal.
Postleitzahl. Ja, nehmen wir mal Frankfurt. 60329.
Äh, ja.
Dann haben wir mal die ganze Technik, was ich hab.
So, das ist alles immer Cheap Aid da oben. Das ist alles immer Werbung.
Kann man das ohne Werbung... Bonus nicht mit einrechnen?
Öko und nachhaltig. Ja, eigentlich würd's mich interessieren, aber ich bin auch auf meinen eigenen Geldbeutel bedacht, also interessiert's mich nicht.
So, kostet jetzt was? Wo steht's?
Tarife und Preisdetails.
Boah, alter!
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Okay, wir gucken mal, ähm... äh... Hanau?
Alter, was ist das für eine komische Seite? Was interessiert mich der Dude hier unten?
Boah, das ist aber schon teuer. Leute, ich kann... Hä? Was ist denn das für eine Logik?
Das heißt, am Charger bei mir in der Stadt ist es billiger aufzuladen.
Da kostet's nämlich bloß 39, äh, Cent für die Kilowattstunde.
Am Charger im Ort ist es billiger aufzuladen demnächst als daheim. Seh ich das richtig?
Gut, die werden den Preis am Charger wahrscheinlich auch erhöhen demnächst.
Ist ja krass. Normalerweise ist es daheim am billigsten gewesen.
Tja, das siehst du mal.
Wie teuer das ist, Alter. What the... Und der Gaspreis, Alter.
Ich will nicht wissen, was ich dann alles Neues, Zusätzliches bezahlen muss Ende des Jahres.
Terabyte reichen da nicht, ja?
Da brauchst du noch ganz andere Größenordnungen.
Was ja nicht funktioniert.
Ey, mittlerweile bist du vielleicht wirklich mit der Oldschool-Technologie billiger als das, was der Strom aus der Steckdose kostet.
Wobei, gut, mein Diesel und Benzin kosten halt auch mega viel aktuell.
Ja, noch, noch. Wahrscheinlich habt ihr einfach einen Vertrag, der möglichst lang läuft.
Wahrscheinlich wird's auch bald dort erhöht.
Ich hab schon geguckt in so ner, in so ner Charge-Map, äh, nach Lidl, Aldi, Edeka und sonst was, die Charger anbieten.
Natürlich, viele Läden wollen mittlerweile, dass man da auch einkauft, wenn man an den Charger geht.
Also, gut, was heißt viele Läden wollen das? Das, oder beim Ikea, ja?
Also viele, die Läden wollten das schon immer, dass man dort einkauft, wenn man dort lädt.
Und es gibt halt immer noch ein paar Leute, die fahren da hin und laden auf und gehen dann nicht einkaufen.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, das rechnet sich dann unterm Strich nicht und irgendwann gibt's die kostenlose Lademöglichkeiten nicht mehr.
Also, ich finde, man sollte zumindest so fair sein, das zu kombinieren.
Ja, dann geh ich dann halt zum, zum Lidl einkaufen anstatt zum Aldi, wenn ich da laden kann.
Solar lohnt sich hauptsächlich, wenn du's selbst nutzt.
Das Beste, was du machen kannst, ist dann selbst den Strom, den du selbst produzierst, selbst benutzen.
Das ist das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Ach nee, du meinst zurück, nee, das lohnt, also, das kann man machen, da gibt's auch ein bisschen was für, aber großartig lohnen tut sich das nicht.
Wenn du halt noch was übrig hast, okay, aber wirklich lohnen richtig tut sich das nur, wenn du den Kram selbst benutzt.
Das heißt, es hat auch keinen Sinn, das wahnsinnig zu überdimensionieren, sodass du was einspeisen kannst.
Also, lohnen tut sich das nur, wenn du möglichst viel selbst verbrauchst.
Und das geht wahrscheinlich auch nur, wenn du, wenn du einen halbwegs brauchbaren Akku hast.
Weil du ja auch mal zu Zeiten, wo die Sonne nicht scheint, was brauchst.
Ja, das, aber damit muss ich mich im Detail nächstes Jahr beschäftigen.
Das krieg ich dieses Jahr nicht mehr hin.
Alles klar.
So.
Also.
Do-it-yourself-Storage-Server.
Allein schon in so einem Gehäuse würde ich keins finden.
Ein Storage-Server bauen.
Aber mal gucken, mal gucken, was ich dazu sage.
Aber ich glaube nicht.
Ich skippe, ich skippe das mal schnell.
Ich glaube nicht, dass mir das gefällt.
Ne, das gefällt.
Ich mein, das geht noch.
Das ist ein Fractal Design R5 oder sowas Gehäuse, oder?
Sieht ziemlich, sieht ziemlich danach aus.
Oder?
Ist es das?
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Das ist, das Gehäuse habe ich schon seit vier, vier PC-Generationen.
Wo ist, wo ist es?
Ja, wie Parts-Used.
Wo ist das Gehäuse?
Kackel.
Parts-Used?
Gehäu-, das Gehäuse gehört natürlich eindeutig nicht zu Parts-Used.
Sind, sind wir uns einig.
Aber das Gehäuse ist ja nicht benutzt worden.
Also, mit diesen Gehäusen geht das noch halbwegs.
Da kannst du immerhin, war das ja heute im Stream schon dran, ausgebremst.
Wenn die Energiewende allerdings, oh, das ist bestimmt wieder so ein Video, wo dann, wo dann irgendwelche, ähm.
Leute von Twitter am Ende kommen und sagen, ja, ja, ja, nein, nein, Klimawandel hat es schon immer gegeben oder sowas.
Gibt es ja immer noch genug.
So, wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben?
Also, so, ähm.
Ja, also, die, das Gehäuse geht ja noch, weil du kriegst die Festplatten halbwegs gescheit rein und raus.
Aber das sind keine Wechselrahmen hier wohlgemerkt.
Vielleicht verkauft es der Hersteller so, aber ist es nicht.
Also, ganz im Ernst, ähm, ich bin kein Fan von diesen Gehäusen für sowas.
Ich bin der Meinung, wenn man einen Storage-Server baut, der sollte an der Front ordentliche Laufwerkschächte haben.
Und sollte so einen, wie heißt das, so einen Hot-Plug-Tray-Wechselrahmen haben.
Alles andere ist doof.
Wie oft wechselst du deine Platten?
Nicht oft.
Nicht, dass sie oft kaputt gehen.
Aber wenn du einen Storage-Server hast mit 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 Platten, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass öfters mal was ist.
8 Platten, es gibt ja sogar irgendwo einen Rechner, ja, müssen wir mal gucken, einen Rechner, wie oft im Durchschnitt was kaputt ist.
Also, ich sag dir mal, ich sag mal so, wenn du wirklich 8 Platten hast, alle 1 bis 2 Jahre ist auf jeden Fall mal was kaputt.
Und dann musst du da dran.
Wenn du Pech hast, auch öfters, weil die Platten zum ähnlichen Zeitpunkt gekauft wurden, sondern musst du da dran.
Und dann hast du das Problem, je nachdem, wo du stehen hast, musst du das Gehäuse, also du musst erst mal ausschalten.
Das ist ja schon mal das Erste.
Du musst ausschalten.
Du musst abmachen.
Du musst das Gehäuse rausziehen.
Du musst aufmachen.
Du musst gucken, welche der Platten davon, die dein RAID meldet, oder was auch immer du verwendest, oder dein, zumindest dein Betriebssystem meldet, ist kaputt.
Ist denn die Platte, die kaputt ist?
Dann musst du die rausziehen.
Dann musst du wahrscheinlich das ganze Tray rausmachen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das geht.
Kabel anschließen, wieder reinmachen.
Das ist Abfuck.
Es hat schon einen Grund, warum die ganzen Nassgeräte, auch für den Heimbereich, die die dir kaufen können, Hotswap-Rahmen vorne dran haben.
Weil das einfach die mit Abstand beste Art und Weise ist, Magnetplatten zu tauschen.
Ja, natürlich ist es teurer.
Aber du brauchst doch keine 8 Festplatten.
8 Festplatten ist totaler Overkill.
3 reicht komplett.
Du musst noch nicht mal, du musst noch nicht mal RAID 5 machen.
RAID 5 ist eh so ein fragwürdiges Ding.
Mit 3 Platten geht es gerade noch so.
Also RAID 5 mit 3 Platten ist das Minimale, was möglich ist und das Maximale, was man machen sollte.
RAID 5 mit mehr als 3 Platten ist ja fast schon...
Kannst du, kannst du gleich RAID 0 machen?
Naja, vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber ja.
Würde ich, würde ich nicht machen.
Ich würde in der heutigen Zeit wahrscheinlich eh keinen RAID mehr machen.
Sondern die Platten einfach lose zusammenhängen oder aber einen RAID 1 machen.
Und einen als Standby drinnen lassen.
Wenn man es wirklich verfügbar haben will.
Aber 8 Platten würde ich auf jeden Fall nicht reinmachen.
Und dementsprechend, und dementsprechend reicht auch ein kleineres Gehäuse.
Und dann kann man sich ordentliche Wechselrahmen leisten.
... plus the cost of drives.
It is more CPU horsepower, double the RAM, more room for expansion
and the overall cost is just a little bit higher than version 1.0.
Okay, aber wir skippen mal.
Ich will auf meinem NAS kein Fortnite spielen.
Hattet ihr auch schon immer mal das Bedürfnis Fortnite auf eurem NAS zu spielen?
Ja, das macht...
Das hier macht mit Wechselrahmen auch nicht viel Sinn.
Also das hier geht noch irgendwo.
Wenn man ein Rack hat, mit Schienen und den Server rausziehen kann.
Und dann relativ easy wechseln.
Aber das ist ja daheim...
Gerade weil du ein komplettes, was ist denn das, 80 cm oder so.
Das ist so eine normale Bautiefe.
Du hast ein komplettes Full-Size-Rack dafür,
was auch die wenigsten Leute daheim stehen haben.
Oder aber du hast es halt oben irgendwo auf dem Tisch liegen.
Ja, geht auch.
Aber trotzdem, du musst wahrscheinlich auch ausschalten, wechseln.
Ist alles... Wechselrahmen ist das Beste, was du brauchst.
Das Problem hier sind die kleinen Lüfter.
Warum?
Das ist halt laut.
Ja, das ist laut.
Das willst du nicht neben dir auf dem Schreibtisch stehen haben.
Die Dinger sind weder energieoptimiert,
also Stromverbrauch günstig, noch sind die leise.
Die Dinger sind dafür gedacht, im Keller im Rechenzentrum zu stehen,
wo es keiner mitkriegt.
Nach Möglichkeit auch noch mit einer Klimaanlage,
dass das quasi von der einen Seite kalte Luft anzieht
und auf der anderen Seite warme Luft abgibt.
Was du daheim auch nicht hast.
Aber was in dem Fall bei einer Kiste kein Problem ist.
Und saubere Luft.
Genau, ohne Staub.
Was du daheim auch nicht hast.
Wo ist eigentlich das... Was hat er denn eigentlich für ein Problem damit?
Ich meine, das macht doch einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Ja, damit hätte ja auch keiner rechnen können,
wenn man sich ein Rechenzentrum-Hardware kauft,
dass sie laut ist.
Also...
Das wäre... Undenk...
Nee, kann nicht sein. Also...
Könnte man nicht drauf kommen können.
Moin, Chainlore.
Aber gut, ausprobieren. Probieren geht über studieren.
Außerdem hat er eindeutig zu wenig RGB-Ram, das stimmt.
Und Lüfter.
Es ist aber...
Ist... Es ist aber...
Also preis-leistung-technisch sind diese Synology-Dinger okay
für das, was man bekommt.
Ich meine, die Hardware an sich, rein von den Spex
die ist natürlich zu teuer.
Ja, da sind dann irgendwelche Dual-Core, hier Pentium-Silber,
sonstwas drin.
Aber die Kombination aus der Hardware, dem Gehäuse,
ähm
Dass es halt einfach funktioniert und den vielen Features, die das Synology Zeug hat, ist das okay?
Also, wenn ich mir ohne groß nachzudenken ein NAS daheim hinstellen wollen würde, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch so ein Synology Ding nehmen.
Was für Platten sind das? 14 Terabyte? Alter, was? Der will da allen Ernstes 8x14 Terabyte reinhauen.
Okay, der hat gewisse Storage-Anforderungen, so wie es aussieht.
Okay, ne, es sind nur 6. Es sind, äh...
Naja, 84.
Der hat bestimmt 5 Usenet-Accounts und Premium-Torrent und Direct-Download und was auch immer.
Der ist den ganzen Tag nur am Saugen.
Und Linux-Distribution runterladen, logischerweise.
Was haben sie geschrieben?
Ah, der wollte YouTube-Bonus nutzen. Kann man machen, warum nicht?
Ich meine...
Ich bin immer noch froh, dass ich damals die 1080 Ti von Nvidia für ein paar Tweets und ein Video bekommen habe.
Die habe ich bis heute...
Also, das war eines der langlebigsten Grafikkarten, die ich je hatte.
Also, das war tatsächlich mal ein Sponsoring, was ich wirklich gelohnt habe.
...Target-Drives.
Und weil diese nicht so nah waren, wie das Dollar-Per-Terabyte-Target, das ich versuchte, zu treffen,
habe ich die Begrüßung, dass ich ihre Offer verabschiede.
Mit der Erfahrung, die ich mit dem letzten Server baut und mit meinem neuen Ziel, es in jeder Weise verbessern zu können,
habe ich angefangen, mein neues System zu verarbeiten.
Jetzt, Version 1.0 hat...
Ich hoffe, er benutzt ECC-RAM und ZFS.
Weil, wenn nicht, wenn er ins ZFS-Forum, äh, ins, ins, ähm, Freenas-Forum geht und schreibt, er benutzt ZFS ohne ECC-RAM,
da kommen die ganzen, äh, selbsternannte Freenas-Elite und erzählt ihm, wie, äh, unmenschlich, unwürdig das ist, äh, ZFS ohne ECC-RAM zu verwenden.
Was natürlich Schwachsinn ist.
ZFS ist auch nicht schlechter als normales Dateisystem ohne ECC-RAM.
Also, das ist jetzt nicht, als würde es dadurch kaputt gehen.
Du merkst manche Fehler vielleicht nicht, was du bei anderen Dateisystemen schon mal gar nicht merkst.
Also, es ist nicht schlechter.
Es ist nicht so, dass du...
Dass dadurch quasi ohne ECC-RAM mehr kaputt geht.
Das wird immer so dargestellt.
Ist es ja nicht.
Ist ja Blödsinn.
Du merkst vielleicht manche Fehler nicht.
Ja, also, es ist schon im Prinzip empfehlenswert, gerade bei so großen Mengen, das dann mit ECC-RAM zu machen, wenn man ZFS verwendet.
Aber es stirbt auch keiner, wenn man mal ZFS ohne ECC-RAM verwendet.
Dadurch geht nicht mehr kaputt.
Du merkst vielleicht manche Sachen nicht, was du bei anderen Sachen erst gar nicht die Chance hättest zu merken.
Fahr nochmal 20 Sekunden zurück.
Meinst du den RAM?
Ist es ECC-RAM?
Ja, müsste, ne?
Hier ist noch ein zusätzlicher, ähm, falls man das überhaupt daran erkennen kann.
Leute, wie erkennt ihr, ob das ECC-RAM ist?
Daran, dass es neun, dass es einer mehr ist?
Der Chat wieder.
Reise-FS.
Wisst ihr überhaupt, dass der Typ, der Reise-FS programmiert hat oder erfunden hat, im Knast sitzt, weil er seine Frau umgebracht hat?
Also, ich glaube, das ist...
Ist schon ne Weile her.
Ist, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr so in den Köpfen der Leute drin.
Der Typ hat seine Frau umgebracht.
Der Reise-FS-Entwickler.
Ja.
Ja, genau der.
Der ist...
Er wurde wegen des Mordes an seiner Ehefrau verurteilt und sitzt gerade im Knast.
Alter, J-Law.
Das ist...
J-Law muss immer so irgendwelche edgy Sachen teilweise schreiben.
In every way I could, I started to part out my new system.
Now, version 1.0 used a pre-built Chenbro NR12000 server that was insanely cheap,
offering pretty much everything other than RAM and drives for around $130.
It was very plug-and-play, but the form factor and hardware had a lot of limitations,
so for this build I went a more custom...
Wo hatten das große...
Das würde mich jetzt interessieren, wo das große...
große Limitations hatte in meinen...
...round, opting to pick out each component individually.
Now, this did cause more work in terms of setup and configuring it,
but the end result was well worth it in my opinion.
Okay, auf geht's.
Also, das Gehäuse finde ich super.
Wie gesagt, ich habe diese Fractal Design Gehäuse schon seit...
...dann.
Drei oder vier PC-Generationen halt immer.
Aktuell stehen sogar zwei nebeneinander, hier, neben dem Schreibtisch.
Eins neuer, bisschen eine Generation.
Aber für so ein System würde ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht unbedingt...
Weiß nicht.
Also, mir widerstreben Storage-Server ohne Wechselrahmen.
Version 2.0 bietet die Möglichkeit, in der Zukunft weit über das, was Version 1.0 möglich war.
Der erste Kauf, den ich gemacht habe, war für die CPU und Motherboard.
Nach der Beobachtung von einigen verschiedenen Optionen,
habe ich die Trigger auf dieses Kombo gelegt,
das aus einer alten HP Z420-Werkstatt herausgekommen ist.
Ich habe nur ein bisschen über 60 Dollar bezahlt.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor, wo man dann wirklich sieht, was Sache ist.
...Tons von PCI-E-Expansion-Schlägen,
was großartig ist, wenn ich etwas machen möchte.
Es ist ein 3-Gigabit-Werkstatt,
standardisiertes Bildungsvermögen.
Okay, ECC-Raum, ja, alles klar.
Massive, massive Lüfter.
Ist das irgendwie giftig oder so?
Ich meine, das ist Waschmittel.
Das war wirklich dreckig.
Schau dir einfach diesen Fan-Filter an.
Ich habe diese sofort aus der Kamera gewaschen.
Alles andere habe ich nur mit einigen Papier-Tauschen und All-Purpose-Kleiner gegeben.
Ja, ich weiß, ich hätte den Hosen haben können.
Nach einigen Preis- und...
Wisst ihr, was richtig nice ist?
Für solche, also, ja, okay, für solche Sachen jetzt vielleicht übertrieben.
Aber was richtig nice ist zum Saubermachen?
So eine Druckluftflasche.
So eine kleine.
Jetzt nicht so eine Taucher, keine Taucherflasche oder so.
Also so eine, so, äh, Druckluftreinigung oder so.
Spray.
Spray-Dose.
Ja, oder einen Kompressor.
Aber sowas hier, solche Dinger.
Ähm, sowas ist, sowas ist ganz praktisch.
Weil, je nach Gerät kann man einfacher reinpusten, als mit dem Staubsauger raussaugen.
Und diese Flaschen sind halt ganz praktisch.
Stöpselst du vorne den Stift rein.
Psst.
So.
Ich hab mal einen Shield TV letzten Zauber gemacht.
Das Shield TV hat die ganze Zeit Krach gemacht mit dem, mit dem Lüfter.
Shield TV aufgemacht, vier, fünfmal reingepustet, mit der Druckluftflasche zugemacht, leise wie neu.
Really dirty.
Just look at this fan filter.
I immediately washed these out off camera.
Everything else, I just gave a good...
Ja, okay, er macht sein Gehäuse sauber.
...SMR storage, which isn't awful for my use case.
But CMR is really what you want for a server application like this one.
If you don't know, you can buy external drives many...
Was war das nochmal?
Das ist...
Ob sich die Festplatten überlagern, ob sich die Magnet-Discs überlagern oder nicht, gell?
SMR und CMR.
Das ist irgendwie, ob die Platten irgendwie übereinander liegen und dann irgendwie rausgerechnet wird, was es wirklich ist.
Da hab ich mich nie so genau mit beschäftigt, aber du kriegst, glaube ich, auf die eine Sache halt mehr Storage drauf für den gleichen Preis.
...many times with a lower price tag than their standalone counterpart.
The big trade-off is a shorter warranty, but it's up to you to decide if the cost savings is worth it.
After...
...after...
...es war mal vor ein paar Jahren total im Trend, dass die Leute sich sowas gekauft haben und dann die Festplatten ausgebaut haben.
Die wurden dann geschackt.
Oder wie nannte sich das?
Schacking?
Oder so geschuckt?
Und geschackt wurden die dann.
...up to you to decide if the cost savings is worth it.
After a bunch of price analysis, I set my sights on 14...
...ausgebaut.
Ausgebautes Wort ist zu und cool.
...external drives and over the course of a month or so bought up six 14TB...
...WD Element Drives at an average cost of $215 a piece or around $1,300 total.
That's pretty good for 84TB of raw capacity and once they were in, it was time to crack them open and see what I got.
Opening these WD Element Drives is actually pretty simple.
It takes some force, but all you have to do is slide the two pieces of the outer shell away from each other.
Then with a little wiggling, the two halves will separate.
You pop out the drive and the four rubber bumps...
Ich muss jetzt gucken, wie man das ausspricht.
Wie spricht man...
Okay, erzähl mal.
Wie spricht man das aus?
Shocking.
Shocking, hab ich doch richtig ausgesprochen.
...will just fall away as they're just pressure fit in.
Then you can unscrew one screw here and another here, which will allow you to pull away the USB adapter PCB...
...and boom, you have a freshly shucked drive.
Ja, was die Amis geritten hat, WW zu nennen, verstehe ich bis heute nicht.
This is a lot quicker than opening the Seagate external drives and took like 10 minutes tops to do all of them.
Ich meine, Ypsilon ist schon echt hängen geblieben.
Aber W...
WD-140E-DGC.
After a bit of research, I believe these are white label versions of WD's 14TB Red Plus drives,
which is awesome as those go for $270 or more, meaning that me waiting for deals on external drives
saved me about $50 per drive or $300 total, which is a pretty significant savings in my opinion.
These are 7200 RPM drives rated for NAS use, making them perfect for my storage server.
Also, these are CMR drives, which are suited...
...much better for storage servers like the one I'm building.
Something to note is some WD drives that have been shucked won't be recognized by your system.
Two of my six drives did this, but the fix is simple.
You can either, like me, use them or you can...
Okay, mal weiter, weiter, weiter, mal ein bisschen vorspulen.
...and an odd connector design...
Was ist das für ein Ding?
...but a normal one will slip right in the...
...and the case will end up, I'm ready to start building the system.
Oder was war das?
Everything went pretty smoothly and the PC luckily booted right up.
...and the PC luckily booted right up.
Some random things to mention is that the fan headers on the motherboard have an extra pin...
...some random things to mention is that the fan headers on the motherboard have an extra pin...
...and an odd connector design, but a normal one will slip right in a place like this.
Also, when installing all the drives, I could only use two screws per sled, as the holes just didn't line up to install more.
With that being said, they're pretty secure and I'm confident in their safety.
I just have the SSDs hanging loose, which is where they'll stay for now.
Other random things used in the build include some of these thin SATA cables...
Das, äh...
Ach, das sind SATA-Kabel. Ich dachte, das ist irgendein SAS-SAS-zu-SATA, woraus am Ende fängt dran kommt.
...some random PC screws I already had lying around.
I also temporarily installed this GT430 as a video out, which will be used for the initial setup of this server.
With the hardware side of things done, I was ready to move on to the software side of things.
For version 1.0, I used Unraid, which was the best option for that configuration.
SAS!
With that being said, now that I have CMR drives and more RAM, I'm gonna go with what I wanted to use originally for version 1.0, which is TrueNAS.
Unraid is great for an archival-based storage server, but TrueNAS in general is better suited for a server being used more actively,
and will give me the ability to do stuff like edit videos directly off of it, and do tons of other stuff.
...
Willst du denn auf TrueNAS direkt...
Ach so, über den lau... über den Stor...
Hä?
Das ist ein Netzwerk-Storage.
Ob jetzt TrueNAS das Netzwerk-Storage macht, oder ob das, ähm, Unraid macht, ist doch vollkommen egal.
Ich mein, gut, mit Unraid machst du keine richtig echten, klassischen Raids, mit TrueNAS schon, aber ich...
bin eh der Meinung, na gut, bei so vielen Festplatten, da könnte ein Raid 6 machen, zum Beispiel.
Raid 6 würde sich anbieten. Er hat sechs Platten, der nimmt vier Platten für Daten und zwei Platten als, ähm, Parity.
Das könnte er machen, dann hat er ziemlich schnelle Read-Performance und die Write-Performance ist auch gut.
Aber die Zugriffszeiten sind halt... naja.
...of other server-related things, like host game servers for my friends and myself.
Also, unlike Unraid, TrueNAS is free and open source. I'm not at all an...
Nutzt doch jemand OpenMediaVault! Nee, ich hab OpenMediaVault aber auch nie richtig benutzt, ich hab's immer ein paar mal ausprobiert, aber so wirklich warm geworden bin ich damit nicht.
...and I'm very much just scratching the surface of all of this.
I will briefly go over the setup process, but for a detailed explanation, I'll link the Crap Computing Tutorial,
create the bootable drives I had to correct and had to redo this procedure, and select boot from UEFI.
So if you're building a server with this same board, make sure to select boot...
UEFI, ich sag immer EFI.
I-I-Ich sag doch nicht mal UEFI.
Ich sag einfach immer EFI.
Ob das jetzt korrekt ist oder nicht, ist mir auch ziemlich egal.
...P, purge pool, I gave the pool a name and hit drive...
Ja, okay, das können wir uns sparen.
...higher.
...I've letter...
...because this is over a gigabit connection, read and write speeds are gonna max out at around 90 megabytes...
Moment, der hat doch nicht mal ne 10G-Karte drinne!
What the fuck?!
...second, but I think I will install a 10 gigabit...
Ja, das ist ja absolut verschenkt.
So viele PCI-Expresse, so viele PCI-Express, und dann so viele Platten, also der kriegt...
...der kriegt lock...
...also, also, also es ist auf jeden Fall, es ist definitiv zu langsam.
...because this is over a gigabit connection, read and write speeds are gonna max out at around 90 meg...
Also 80, das ist, das ist definitiv zu langsam, selbst für Gigabit, und, ähm...
...der kriegt, mit den vielen Platten kriegt der locker das, das 4-5-fache.
...megabytes per second, but I think I will install a 10 gigabit NIC in this machine that will connect directly to a 10 gigabit NIC in my PC, which will enable me to...
Ja.
...einfach einen 10 gigabit, wird noch einen 10 gigabit Switch holen, die sind ja teilweise gar nicht mehr so teuer, wenn man den richtigen holt.
...edit off of it directly.
If you wanna see an update video in the future, where I add more RAM, upgrade the CPU, add SSD cache, and add 10 gigabit networking to this server, then let me know in the comment section below.
Again, this server is just housing files right now, but with the ability to have a high core count...
Ich mein, immerhin, immerhin ist da kein Windows-Server auf dem Ding.
...CPU and 64 gigs of RAM, it means there's a ton of...
Naja, okay, alles klar.
Das...
Das Video hätten wir uns jetzt auch sparen können, ehrlich gesagt.
So, was schauen wir uns als nächstes an?
Essential...
Ne, wir...
Wir lassen uns Level-Capture baten.
Ne, ne, ich will nicht wissen, wie John Carmack sein WIMP verwendet.
Ähm...
Level-Capt...
Wir lassen uns ohne Level-Capture baten.
Auf geht's.
This week in gaming.
Wetten, dass er uns wieder erzählt...
Huge changes in Battlefield 2042.
Und am Ende fragt er uns...
Und denkt er jetzt, dass Battlefield 2042 in einem besseren Spot ist?
Und ich weiß nicht...
Ich weiß, dass ich jedes Mal das gleiche zu dem sag, was er sagt.
...2042 Season 2 was revealed.
PlayStation made some pretty bad decisions, Amazon might buy EA, and much more on this week in gaming.
Amazon kauft EA.
Aber wisst ihr was ganz im Ernst?
Amazon kriegt mit Games überhaupt nichts auf die Reihe.
Also, dass Amazon mal einen Spielehersteller kauft, beziehungsweise...
Ups.
...Battlefield 2042 Season 2...
Ähm...
Irgendwas, was mehrere Rechte an unterschiedlichen Spieleherstellern hat, das wäre vielleicht gar nicht so blöd.
...revealed.
PlayStation made some pretty bad decisions, Amazon might buy EA, and much more on this week in gaming.
DICE revealed Battlefield 2042's second season this week.
It'll go live on all platforms on August 30th.
Season 2 offers a bit more content than Season 1, but players are concerned it still won't be enough to keep them satisfied.
It introduces the new stranded map, which is a smaller space than the other 2042 maps.
Season 2 also adds a new...
Alter!
Diese Container Maps, man!
Diese Container Maps!
Warum?
Die haben nur Container auf allen Maps mittlerweile.
...New Support Specialist named Crawford.
His special gadget is a minigun emplacement that comes with a ballistic shield.
Three new weapons, two new vehicles, and a new concussion grenade are also shipping with Season 2.
And despite the update not boasting a lot of content, it does appear to be in line with the community's expectations for quality and design.
Several weapons from 2042's portal mode are also being added into All Out Warfare.
DICE refers to them as Vault Weapons.
Ich meine, wer designt solche Maps?
...that must be unlocked through a new assignment system.
The M60E4 and M16A3 from Battlefield 3 are the first to go live, but other portal weapons will follow throughout the season.
As will the two new map reworks with Renewal and Orbital.
This week's episode of Inside Star Citizen...
Also, danach...
Es kann sich doch keiner bei DICE wirklich mal später woanders bewerben als Level Designer.
Und die fragen dann ja, zeig doch mal ein bisschen was.
Ja, zeig doch mal ein bisschen was, was du gebaut hast.
Und da zeigt er ihnen drei Maps, die aus Containern bestehen.
Die sind dann so Leute, die dürfen dann das fünfte Shipment Remake für Modern Warfare 25 bauen.
Okay, Star Citizen juckt mich nicht.
Warzone Launch juckt mich eigentlich auch nicht.
Das interessiert mich.
Investors and Gamers were equally surprised this week,
when rumors circulated that tech giant Amazon was planning to acquire Electronic Arts.
The report came from the Swedish Gaming Agency, GLHF.
They claimed that Amazon was set to buy EA.
However, just an hour after...
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass wir das sehen.
Das mit Microsoft und Activision war schon ein Hammer.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt mittlerweile eigentlich mal durch ist.
Aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
...released, analysts from CNBC shot down the rumor, stating that Amazon had no plans of acquiring EA.
It's long been rumored that the gaming giant would be bought by somebody, but who knows...
Du kennst einen, der bei DICE arbeitet, der durfte nur die Finger modellieren.
Ist aber...
Die bezahlen dem ganz schön viel Geld dafür, dass er nur Finger modelliert, oder?
Na gut, in einem Shooter ist die Hand gar nicht so unwichtig, weil das das einzige ist, was du von einem Charakter siehst.
...knows what the future actually holds for this company.
Sony announced that both models of its PlayStation 5 console would receive a price increase worldwide.
In most regions the price increases around $50.
Sony claims the price increases due to the world's economic state, and that the cost of production has forced them to raise the price.
Thankfully, Microsoft and now...
Natürlich, natürlich.
Komm, sobald es möglich ist und die wissen, dass die Leute einen höheren Preis akzeptieren, machen sie das.
...but it wouldn't be changing the price of its series consoles, making them an even better deal than before.
Despite this, Sony still holds the majority of sales in most regions.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es keine Spiele für die Xbox gibt.
In better news, Sony did reveal their new controller.
The DualSense Edge features everything found on the base controller, while offering many customization features.
They include remappable buttons, stick sensitivity tuning and faster input.
No release date or price has been shared yet.
In other PlayStation news, Sony are being sued in the UK for allegedly overcharging consumers for their games over the past six years.
Flexible Gaming Monitor.
Da hat der Bauer ein Video zugemacht, das können wir uns angucken.
Juckt mich nicht.
Neue Grafikkarten-Serie.
Nvidia's CEO confirmed that they would finally share concrete details on the new RTX 40 Series graphics card at the GTC event in September.
During Nvidia's investor call this week, where the company reported a 44% revenue decline,
the CEO ended things on a high note by stating that the new GPUs would be revealed very soon.
Enthusiasts have speculated for months about what performance...
Revealed soon.
Da hätte er auch genau so wenig sagen können.
...the RTX card will offer, and thankfully we'll know for sure in just a few weeks.
Rumors online suggest the next-gen RTX cards will be very power-hungry.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gehört.
Before we get to our next story, I'd love to hear your thoughts on Battlefield 2042's Season 2 Contra.
Der macht immer das Gleiche, Alter.
Es war so klar, dass der das fragen wird.
Weg damit.
Reicht für heute. Genug Level Capture bait.
Das war ihm zu langweilig und jetzt macht er Augmented Reality. Aha.
Da braucht man aber auch Finger.
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Homelab Tools.
God Tier Developer Roadmap.
Das ist ein Fireship-Video.
Okay, wir lassen uns von Fireship erklären, wie wir ein God Tier Developer werden.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Wir können uns auch vom Bauer das neue 240 Hz OLED Display angucken.
Das ist kurz gesagt. Die haben teilweise auch Titel in letzter Zeit.
Warum ich hier anders heiße?
Weil ich den Account schon lange angelegt habe, bevor ich selbst streamen wollte.
Und dann dachte ich mir so, weißt du was, nimmst du einfach den Account, dann erkennst auch nicht so viele Leute.
Weil es ist einfach so, auf YouTube haben wir schon einige Deppen.
Und alle, die es hierher finden und nicht anhand des Namens, die sind High IQ und passen hier gut rein.
Okay, God Tier Developer.
Okay, zeig her.
You've likely seen videos on YouTube telling you the number one programming language to learn right now if you want to be rich.
That's not what we're doing today.
Instead, we're going to travel to the deepest, darkest depths of the software engineering field to discover the programming languages that are loved, hated, beautiful, ugly, compiled, interpreted, useful, weird and everything.
Moment, wo ist meine Lieblingssprache?
Sekunde.
Gut, das C++ da unten ist, das finde ich schon mal angebracht.
Rust.
C Sharp. C Sharp ist auf.
Wo?
Leicht unterhalb der Meeresoberfläche.
Okay, also quasi Layer 4.
Na, wenn er das sagt.
Beautiful, ugly, compiled, interpreted, useful, weird and everything in between.
If you make it to the end, you'll have a roadmap for everything you need to know to land a job as a junior developer in 2023.
Scratch ist das, was Battlefield 2042 benutzt in Portal.
Or it might just make you extremely depressed.
Because this iceberg is just the tip of the iceberg of what you actually need to learn.
Choose any language and you'll find another iceberg within this iceberg.
Das ist kein Witz, ich meine das ernst.
Guckt euch gleich mal an.
Ich hoffe, der zeigt was.
Ja, der zeigt was.
Which ironically you can represent in code with any one of the languages we're about to look at.
Before we get started, there's quite a few programming icebergs out there.
But this one ranks languages based on where I think you might encounter them as a beginner learning how to code from scratch.
Each level has its own theme, so let's get right into it.
Er ist auch ein Ironside-Enjoyer, wie ich sehe, das ist schon mal gut.
Let's get right into it.
There are several languages that are designed to make programming as easy as possible.
If you know absolutely nothing about programming, the best place to start, in my opinion, is Scratch.
It was developed at MIT, like some other languages on this list, but instead of typing out code...
Ja, guckt euch das an.
Das ist der Portal-Logik-Editor.
Fast 1 zu 1.
...you drag and drop these blocks together like...
Guckt, hat schon gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
...like Lego bricks to represent things like...
Wobei, nee, wir haben ja nachgeguckt, Portal ist, glaube ich, Blockly, aber das geht alles in die gleiche Richtung.
...variables, control flow and operators.
It makes the thinking process behind programming much more accessible, and you might be surprised at what you can actually build with it.
Long before Scratch, though, we had Basic, or Beginners All-Purpose Symbolic Instruction, which came out of dirt.
Ein Taschenrechner zu machen ist tatsächlich schwierig, weil du musst Texts zu mathematischen Sachen parsen.
Die meisten Leute machen ja aber ein Taschenrechner höchstens mit Buttons.
Zum Klicken oder sowas wie, geben Sie die erste Zahl ein, geben Sie die zweite Zahl ein und sowas.
Das ist natürlich easy, aber String zu mathematischen Sachen parsen ist schwierig.
...Bertmuth in 1964.
At the time, Fortran was all the rage, but it wasn't beginner-friendly.
Basic provides a bunch of basic commands, like print, goto and for, and was included in most personal computers,
which made it the goto option for people learning to code for the next 50 years.
Now, moving on to the next tier.
We have the extremely popular, dynamic, high-level languages.
The language most people start with today is Python, primarily because of its minimal syntax.
It doesn't require curly braces, semicolons, and stuff like that,
and instead uses indentation to represent different blocks of code.
The other popular high-level language is JavaScript.
Syntactically, it's pretty ugly, but it's a requirement if you want to do web development,
and almost every developer will have to touch it at some point in their career.
Da hat er recht, das sage ich auch immer. An JavaScript kommst du eigentlich nicht vorbei.
Also an ein bisschen Web-Entwicklung, also der Klassiker aus JavaScript, HTML, CSS, kommst du nicht dran vorbei.
Vielleicht als IBM-Mainframe-Kobol-Entwickler für 50 Jahre.
...will eventually be written in JavaScript.
Now, after learning one of these languages, you'll be able to build pretty much anything you can imagine,
and you could have an entire career as a software engineer.
Jetzt muss ich dich fragen, Gurke, was sagst du? Welche Programmiersprache ist gut?
Wenn Python Schmutz ist für dich, jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich C++ oder irgendwie sowas.
...without going any further down the iceberg.
But you don't want to be on your deathbed wondering if you should have tried out PHP.
On this next tier, we have languages that are extremely popular, but a little more specialized.
Programmers like to get things done from the terminal, and there are scripting languages like Bash and PowerShell
that allow you to interact with your computer programmatically.
Also ich muss ja sagen, PowerShell. PowerShell an sich finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, was Microsoft da gebaut hat.
Allerdings finde ich ist PowerShell eklig interaktiv zu nutzen.
Irgendwelche Automatisierungssachen in PowerShell zu skripten ist okay, für interaktive Sachen ZSH oder Bash.
...instead of typing out the same commands over and over again, write a Bash script to make it reproducible.
Now, if you get into web development, you'll also need to learn HTML and CSS,
which when combined together arguably form a Turing-complete programming language.
They're not used for programming in the traditional sense, but rather to define the structure and style of a website.
And if I were to say HTML is not a programming language, I would be immediately cancelled by the tech community.
In addition, most apps need a database, and the most common language for working with databases is structured query language.
You can call it SQL, SQL, or SQUIL. This Turing-complete...
Also ich persönlich bin ja jemand, der SQL sagt.
Wie hammer, wie sieht's bei euch so aus? SQL? SQL? SQUIL?
Also ich mag SQL.
Und dann auch so wirklich die deutsche Aussprache, S-Q-L.
Genau, S-Q-L.
...although not used for regular programming, but rather to read and write data in a relational database.
Wobei wir ja wissen, dass Jason eigentlich gar nicht Jason heißen soll, sondern Jazon.
Oder so.
Haben wir doch letztens in einem Video gesehen, wo der Jason-Erfinder gemeint hat, es müsste eigentlich Jazon heißen.
...but there are many other dynamic languages that might be a better fit for certain languages.
Sachen, wo die Arrays bei 1 anfangen, sind mir äußerst
suspekt.
Ja, dass Roblox den
Crap verwendet, wundert mich nicht.
Ruby ist richtig. Ganz ehrlich,
ich bin immer noch ein
großer Ruby-Fan, aber
es gibt halt in letzter Zeit kaum Gründe mehr,
was in Ruby zu machen, geschweige denn Web-Anwendungen
heute in Rails zu machen.
Ja.
Okay.
Außer die China-Chinesen, die mögen Java.
Guckt mal die Trenden, guckt euch die GitHub-Trends aus China an.
Das ist gefühlt fast alles Java.
Aber was bei denen los ist, weiß ich nicht.
Jawohl, die C-Sharp-Giga-Jets am Start.
Also wenn ich wirklich eine Mobile-App bauen würde,
würde ich mir angucken, wie gut das mit Avalonia 11 geht,
vielleicht ist das eine Alternative.
Und ansonsten, ganz ehrlich,
ich würde irgendwelche JavaScript-Sachen nehmen.
Ionic oder irgendwie sowas.
Wenn ich wirklich eine Mobile-App bauen müsste.
Gibt es eigentlich eine gescheite C-Sharp-EDE für Linux?
Ja, nicht nur für Linux, für Mac, Windows und Linux.
Genau, Rider, richtig.
Was der Chat auch schon gesagt hat.
Das ist auch das, was ich immer in den Streams verwende.
Ich habe mir bei JetBrains mal vor zwei, drei Jahren
dieses All-Desktop-Products-Pack gekauft.
Ich will alles, genau.
Für persönliche Nutzung.
All-Products-Pack.
Da bezahlst du...
Ach, neue Preise, es wird teuer.
Da bezahl...
Also ich habe es jetzt schon eine ganze Weile,
da bezahle ich 150 Euro im Jahr für alles.
Boah!
Jetzt aber!
Dann zahle ich 173 Euro demnächst.
Was willst du machen?
Ja, jährlich mache ich.
Da ist halt alles dabei.
Da ist...
Ähm...
Was ist denn alles dabei?
Ja.
Dabei...
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken.
Was ist das überhaupt alles, was da dabei ist?
Also.
Rider.
R.
R++.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Go.
PS.
Äh...
PHP.
Die PHP.
Webstorm.
Sea Lion.
Keine Ahnung.
Data...
Dings...
Grip.
Keine Ahnung.
Äh...
PyCharm.
IntelliJ.
Ruby Mine.
Der Rest sagt mir auch nichts.
Ach, steht ja auch dabei.
Lul.
Hätten wir vielleicht mal unten gucken sollen, was es ist.
Ach, App Code.
Äh...
Ihh...
Das ist irgendwelches iOS-Zeug.
Goland.
Ja.
Also was...
Bei mir lohnt es sich halt insofern.
Ich verwende von denen das da.
Und ich verwende von denen das da.
Ab und zu...
Ab und zu verwende ich das da.
Und...
Ja, die könnte ich...
Ne, äh...
Die könnte ich eigentlich verwenden.
Aber da bin ich bei Visual Studio Code.
Manchmal...
Also so irgendwie einmal die letzten fünf Jahre Ruby Mine, wenn es so irgendwelche Ruby-Sachen gibt.
Wo sind wir?
Verstehen geblieben?
Ja.
Next up we have Go, which is a high-performance language developed at Google to build low-level systems.
It was designed as...
Blazingly fast written in Go.
Ganz wichtig in die Readme.
...as a replacement for C.
And Ken Thompson, one of the original creators of C, helped design it.
The syntax is nice and concise, making it approachable to beginners.
And it has a garbage collector, which means unlike C, developers don't need to worry about manual memory management.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich bin gar nicht so großer Fan der Go-Syntax.
Wir haben jetzt ja auch ein paar Sachen in Go gemacht.
Also...
Schön finde ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
At this point, we've reached the level of the iceberg, where most people are afraid to go any deeper.
Things are gonna get weird.
What happens is that many developers get jaded with these big, heavy, object-oriented languages and go searching for a better way.
At this level, we have functional languages.
The most famous of which is Haskell.
Instead of classes, inheritance and all kinds of crazy design patterns, the only abstraction you really need is the function.
It was inspired by the Miranda.
The language and is named after the mathematician Haskell Curry.
Most importantly, variables are immutable and functions have no side effects.
Surprisingly, you can build almost anything with these limitations, although most production code out there is not functional.
Most of us run into problems when trying to figure out what a monad is, which in layman's terms is just a monoid in the category of n-functors.
Haskell is great, but Microsoft developed a functional sister language to C-sharp called F-sharp.
Unlike Haskell, which is purely functional, F-sharp is also imperative and object-oriented,
making it more approachable to the...
The big advantage of F-sharp is that it runs on the .NET runtime,
which means you can easily make an interop between C-sharp and F-sharp.
And, now hold on, WISHELBASIC.NET!
...developers coming from higher up in the iceberg.
Now, if you hate Java, a good alternative is Scala.
Like F-sharp, it supports both object-oriented and functional programming, but it runs on the JVM.
It's statically typed, but there's another JVM language called Clojure,
that is both functional and dynamic.
This makes it more well-suited for getting things...
Oh, das ist dieser Lisp-Abklatsch, oder? Der eben, der nur aus Klammern besteht.
...done quickly, with the trade-off of type safety.
Other popular functional languages include OCaml, which is used extensively at Facebook,
and Elixir, which has a very nice Ruby-like syntax,
and is capable of building high-performance, real-time web apps.
Wisst ihr, was das Problem ab diesem Iceberg-Layer schon ist?
Das mag... Das mögen alles coole Sprachen,
mit coolen Ideen sein, die sich für manche Sachen auch super eignen,
aber du findest keine Leute, die das können.
Versuch mal sowas... Versuch damit mal im größeren...
Oh, komplex, ja, dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen.
Library-Auswahl sicherlich auch nicht so der Wahnsinn bei den meisten,
aber versuch mal damit was zu programmieren in einem größeren Team,
du findest ja gar keine Leute, die das verstehen.
So Helm, which is a purely functional language that compiles to Javascript,
which can build front-end UIs with zero runtime errors,
but now it's time to go one level deeper to the heart of the iceberg.
These languages are absolute chads.
They're low-level systems languages that can manually manage and optimize memory
and are used to build things like operating system kernels and compilers
that make all the other source-based languages possible.
The most legendary of which is C.
It was used to build the Windows, Mac and Linux operating system kernels,
and its curly-braced syntax inspired many other languages on this list.
Surprisingly, it's not all that hard to learn
and has a relatively small set of keywords.
Also, rein vom Ansatz her ist C tatsächlich vom Sprachumfang her nicht schwierig zu lernen.
Das Problem an C ist, dass du auf sehr viele Sachen achten musst
und manches wirklich durch die Brust ins Auge ist.
Also, da werden Sachen nach VoIP-Pointers gecastet,
um sie dann irgendwie als Pointer rumzureichen durch zig Funktionen,
wo sie dann irgendwann wieder zurückgecastet werden.
Also, da den Überblick zu behalten, ist nicht so ohne.
Auto gibt es in C... Moment, es gibt in C Auto?
Ich dachte, es ist eine C++-Geschichte.
Schlimmste, was es gibt, Leute.
Schlimmste, was es gibt.
Schlimmste, was es gibt, ey.
Der Witz war gar nicht schlecht mit dem Pointer und der...
und... und...
und...
Ich meine, das Pointer heißt logischerweise nicht so, weil es so ist, als schießt einer
auf dich, aber hat schon gewisse Parallelen.
Software, like game engines, compilers and so on.
C and C++ are still extremely relevant today, but the modern Chad tends to prefer Rust for
low-level programming.
Blazingly fast written in Rust.
It doesn't have a garbage collector, but unlike C and C++, it uses a technique called
borrow checking instead of pointers for memory management.
This makes it much easier to write memory-safe programs and consistently ranks as the most
loved language in the world.
The languages on this tier are extremely popular, but now we descend further into the modern
languages that you...
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was die Hälfte davon ist.
Nimm, kenn ich, das ist SIG, das haben wir letztens auch gesehen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das ist VLAN, ich weiß nicht, wofür man es verwendet.
Und von den anderen habe ich keine Ahnung, was es sein soll.
Es wäre schon praktisch, wenn man anhand des Logos irgendwie erkennt, was es sein soll.
Ach, Carbon ist ja auch noch.
Das ist ja noch ganz neu.
Es hat noch nie einer von SIG was gehört, gibt's zu.
Ihr habt erst was von SIG gehört, als letztens diese JavaScript-Runtime rausgekommen ist,
die in SIG programmiert war.
Niemand hat vorher was von SIG gehört.
Ich habe noch nie was von SIG gehört.
...when it comes to memory management.
And it can cross-compile C and C++, just like Clang.
SIG is not to be confused with NIM, another high-performance language that's very expressive
like Python, but is statically typed, and interestingly, it has a tunable garbage collector
that can be turned off altogether to enable manual memory management.
Recently, Google announced Carbon, designed to be a successor to C++.
What makes it special is that it can fully interop with a legacy C++ codebase.
Another low-level specialty language...
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich Carbon...
...gross durchsetzen wird.
...which is Solidity.
It's a statically typed object-oriented language, but is designed for implementing smart contracts,
especially on the Ethereum blockchain.
Then we've got Hack from Facebook, which is designed to interop with PHP.
The original website was built with PHP, but they needed a language with better performance
and a type system to scale it up to the monstrosity that it is today.
There are many other good modern languages at this point in the iceberg, like Crystal,
Hacks, and Pharaoh, just to name a few.
Crystal kenne ich.
Crystal, das sind die, die Ruby nachbauen wollten.
Ähm, die einen Ruby-Compiler ursprünglich bauen wollten und da eine eigene Sprache draus gebaut haben.
...but now it's time to go down to the next level, where we look at languages that are still either widely used or historically important,
but not something you would likely choose to program in.
Fortran was the first high-level programming language and was by far the most popular language for many years until C came around.
Not long after Fortran, Lisp was invented in 1958.
It pioneered many...
Lisp ist für alle Leute, die Klammern mögen.
...ideas we take for granted in computer science.
Alter, ich find Lisp so'n Tag so hässlich, es gibt ja Leute, die schwören da drauf, ich find das so abartig.
...dynamic typing, higher-order functions, recursion, and repel.
It inspired many other languages like Racket, Scheme, Clojure, and to a certain extent JavaScript.
Another highly influential language that came out this year was algorithmic language.
It's a big, complex language and never got as popular as Fortran,
but its type system and use of expressions had a major influence on the development of C and C++.
The following year, in 1959, COBOL was born.
Endlich!
Wo sind die COBOL-Chats?
Endlich mal ne ordentliche Sprache.
Endlich. Ja.
Wurt auch mal. Zeit.
Only high IQ.
Leute, ich hab mehr COBOL-Erfahrung...
Ich sag euch jetzt mal wirklich die Wahrheit.
Ich hab mehr COBOL-Erfahrung als 99,99% der Weltbevölkerung.
Wenn's reicht.
Was nicht heißt, dass ich gut COBOL kann.
Aber ich hab immerhin schon mal was kleines in COBOL gemacht.
If you want to make money in the 2020s, learn COBOL.
Because over 40% of banking systems still use it, with over 200 billion...
Nein, nein, nicht mit Stechkern. Das war schon genug COBOL, was wir gemacht haben.
Leute, wer es nicht glaubt, Archiv...
Wir haben das bestimmt im Archiv drin. Pass mal auf hier. COBOL.
COBOL. Da ist es.
Leute. COBOL. Hier.
Mit der passenden Schriftart dazu.
Guckt euch das Elend mal an, Leute.
Accept keck win from sysin.
Also, wer es mir nicht glaubt, massive COBOL-Erfahrung.
... in lines of code in production today.
In 62 APL first appeared, which stands for A programming language.
It implements linear algebra directly into the language with a multidimensional array or matrix being the central data type.
This leads to extremely terse code that resembles mathematical notation and makes heavy use of the Greek alphabet.
In 1970 Pascal was invented and took the programming world by storm.
It's a procedural language with a familiar syntax...
Man kann es wenigstens lesen.
... and also had very fast compile times.
It eventually became the most popular language in the early 1980s before the rise of C a few years later.
There are many other important languages from this time period, like Simula, the first object-oriented language that went on to inspire Smalltalk,
which itself inspired many other object-oriented languages like Python, Java and Ruby.
Then there's Erlang, a concurrent functional programming language that basically powered the entire telecom industry and is still in use today.
There's Ada, a general purpose language named after Ada.
Ada Lovelace, who's generally considered the world's first computer programmer.
It was extremely popular in the 1980s and is still used today by the Department of Defense to blow people up.
In addition, we should mention Prolog, the language that pioneered logic programming,
and Meta-Language, which pioneered the polymorphic type system,
used by other statically typed functional languages like Haskell.
There are many other historical languages we could talk about, but now it's time to descend into the realm of the esoteric,
where we find rare and bizarre language...
Holy, holy C! Ist da bestimmt dabei!
...that feel more like works of art than engineering tools.
The first known esoteric language came out in 1972 and was called Intercal.
Also, wenn da Holy C. nicht drin ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
...with no pronounceable acronym.
It was designed as a parody to make fun of the languages of the day, like ALGOL and FORTRAN.
It has an entire paradoxical reference manual that makes no sense,
and has an interesting choice of keywords like please and mingle.
Please doesn't actually do anything, but it makes you a more polite programmer.
Next up we have Brainfuck.
Brainfuck is most well known for being extremely minimal.
Urban Muller created Brainfuck in college,
and it works by initializing an array,
then gives you a pointer and eight different characters to manipulate memory in that array.
This results in a codebase that will fuck your brain up.
It inspired another language called Male Bulge,
or maybe it's Malbulgia,
which is named after the eighth circle of hell in the Divine Comedy or Dante's Inferno.
If you thought Brainfuck was difficult, this language takes things to a whole nother level.
It makes programming so difficult...
Ah, ja.
Jetzt ist alles klar, wenn ich das sehe.
...that I can't even summarize how it works.
In a single sentence.
If that's a little too dark, a far more fun language is Chef,
which is stack-based and is designed to make your code look like a cooking recipe.
Instead of concise keywords, it uses sentences like
put ingredient into mixing bowl to push a value onto the stack.
Put these commands together to create a hello world souffle,
then specify how many it serves to write it to the standard output.
That's pretty cool, but it may seem kind of silly to an intellectual.
The Shakespeare programming language will make your code look like a Shakespearean play.
It provides the low-level control of assembly,
with the verbosity of 16th century poetry.
But if words aren't really your thing, then a good language choice would be Piette,
which is named after Piette Mondrian.
It's also stack-based, but you write code,
utilizing patterns of 20 different colors on a bitmap image.
Alter, it's übertreibt halt.
The end result is a codebase that looks like abstract art.
Now, if you're a crazy cat lady, you're really going to love this next language.
LOL code.
Which provides a developer experience similar to an LOL cat meme.
You open a program by saying hi, then end it by saying k thanks bye.
Loops can be performed with I'm in your,
or broken out of with I'm out of your.
That's nice and easy to understand, but it would be even better if it included emojis.
Emojicode is a language where the syntax is entirely based on emojis.
Modern developers like to use so many emojis in their documentation,
that this language would just streamline the entire process.
It's a fully-featured, object-oriented language,
where you can define code blocks with grapes and watermelons,
classes with rabbits, and generics with shells and eggplants.
Another language that's not necessarily esoteric is C-minus-minus.
It's designed as a portable assembly language that borrows heavily from C,
but omits many of its features.
The ultimate dialect of C, though, is Holy C.
Endlich. Da hab ich drauf gewartet.
Pregel.
Which was created by Terry A. Davis and used to build Temporal Ass.
Der hatte auch wirklich einen harten Dachschaden.
Holy C is actually really cool, because it works like C,
but it's just in time compiled on the operating system,
which means you can use it like a scripting language
that can interact directly with the operating system kernel.
And that brings us to the final tier,
the absolute lowest level you can go with your learning as a software engineer.
Assembly is a language of which there are many variations
that correspond directly to the architecture on the CPU.
Different CPU architectures like x86 and ARM require different machine code instructions.
Assembly allows you to represent this code with simple commands
that manipulate values on the CPU.
Bestes. Bestes. Rollercoaster Tycoon.
Now, if that looks too easy, the next level down is machine code.
At this point, we're looking at ones and zeros, or raw binary,
usually represented in hexadecimal format.
To code at this level, you'll need to have intimate knowledge of the computer's architecture
and also be able to count in binary.
But if we go beyond machine code, now we're looking at billions of transistors on a CPU.
A single transistor represents one bit, like a one or a zero,
by controlling the amount of electricity
that flows through a piece of silicon.
Now, in order to do anything useful,
the transistors need to be organized into logic gates,
like NOT, AND, OR, EXCLUSIVE OR,
bald baut er seinen eigenen Krypto-Miner,
OR and so on.
Ultimately, it's these very simple chunks of logic
that perform the miracle of taking some electricity as an input
that can produce some other electricity as an output
and do it billions of times per second all over the world
so you can play video games with your friend in Vietnam.
If that was too easy, then you may want to look into the field
of quantum electrodynamics.
To fully understand how these particles behave
in the electromagnetic quantum vacuum.
You can then use your skills to build a next-gen,
blazingly fast quantum computer
and become the richest person
Ist der dann auch written in rust?
in history.
At this point in the iceberg, there's only one place left to go.
The scariest place of all, yourself.
Once you know everything, the question becomes,
what is knowledge?
Epistemology is the theory of knowledge,
and philosophers still don't have a good answer to this day.
Reality only exists within my own mind.
For all I know, the entire external world
and all the knowledge I've acquired
are just illusions and projections from my own ego.
Maybe there's a godlike being that controls all the sensations
and knowledge received by my mind,
or perhaps my real body isn't a vat of goo
and I'm already living in Zuckerberg's metaverse.
Or maybe I never came out of that ayahuasca trip I took 10 years ago.
The only thing I really know is that I know nothing.
Thanks for watching, and I will see you in the next one.
Subtitles by Stephanie Geiges
Zeug daheim?
Doch, doch, doch, oh nee, das ist wieder...
Painsjump.
Warum bist du nicht auf der Gamescom?
Weil ich kein...
keine wirkliche Daseinsberechtigung für die Gamescom als Messe mehr sehe.
Das einzig Coole an der Gamescom ist,
wenn man sich gerne mit Leuten trifft,
und ich würd mich tatsächlich auch mal...
Ich bin nicht so der Allersozialste, was das angeht,
aber so ein paar Leute fänd ich echt ganz cool,
wenn man die mal wieder sieht.
Aber dafür nach Köln fahren, Hotel buchen,
da übernachten, hinfahren, zurückfahren mit der Bahn.
Äh, nee.
Es ist auch relativ stressig.
Du musst im Vorfeld jede Menge Termine machen,
weil wenn du keine Termine machst,
dann musst du dich halt anstellen für Stunden.
Ja.
Also nur wenn jemand denkt,
weil man eine Gamescom-Akkreditierung hat,
kommt man überall rein.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, so ist das nicht.
Ihr müsst im Vorfeld Termine machen,
sonst müsst ihr euch anstellen wie alle anderen auch.
Oder ihr kriegt halt irgendeinen Pass oder so.
Wenn ihr bei denen dann in der Business-Area wart
und die sagen, hier, guckt euch das doch nochmal an,
ihr habt den Zettel, dann geht das.
Aber in der Regel musst du dich da genauso anstellen
wie alle anderen auch.
Deswegen, du musst da wirklich richtig was vorbereiten,
wenn du auf die Gamescom fährst.
Du musst Wochen vorher Termine machen,
du musst das alles planen,
musst dir ein Hotel buchen,
du musst gucken, wie du hin- und zurückkommst,
du musst gucken, wie das einteilt, tagestechnisch.
Dann tun dir erst mal die Waden weh,
weil du es nicht gewohnt bist, so viel zu laufen.
Wobei mittlerweile, ähm,
ja, mittlerweile mit meinen 15 abgenommenen Kilo
täglich eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden rumlaufen,
dürften mir die Waden wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so wehtun
auf der Gamescom, aber trotzdem.
Also erste Gamescom-Nacht habe ich nie richtig geschlafen,
weil mir die Waden wehgetan haben.
Das war erst so ab Mittag zweiter Tag wieder gut.
Und außerdem ist es halt langweilig auf der Gamescom.
Ist wirklich so.
Genauso wie Knorsten sagt,
wenn du nicht gerade wirklich Bock hast,
dir Cosplay anzugucken,
weil du ja selbst Cosplayer bist,
oder eben dich mit Leuten zu treffen,
die Gamescom, ehrlich gesagt,
ziemlich unspektakulär und langweilig.
Zumal dieses Jahr die großen Hersteller auch gar nicht da sind,
aber selbst wenn die da sind,
es werden doch kaum wirklich interessante Games da gezeigt.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Gamescom muss ich nicht mehr machen.
Ich glaube, da habe ich ein paar mal gemacht.
Reicht mir voll und ganz.
Ja, wäre ganz cool, da mal wieder ein paar Leuten über den Weg zu laufen,
äh, die man, die man kennt,
die man da vielleicht schon auch eine Weile nicht mehr gesehen hat,
oder vielleicht die man nur von Twitter oder aus dem Internet kennt,
mal kurz Hallo sagen kann,
alles in Ordnung, das ist schon nice.
Was ich halt, ganz ehrlich,
wisst ihr, was ich am meisten an der Gamescom mochte?
Das war gar nicht die Gamescom an sich,
sondern das war, dass man einfach mal,
ähm,
eine Woche,
drei, vier Tage, ich war ja nie die komplette Woche da,
dass man drei, vier Tage
mal so in einer anderen Welt
einfach im Kopf war.
Du hast quasi deinen normalen Tagesablauf,
und sonst wie, du hast einfach an nichts gedacht,
was du sonst immer so denkst,
und hattest einfach mal drei, vier Tage so ein bisschen andere Welt.
Ja.
Ersten Tag musst du dich dran gewöhnen,
dass du mit vielen gebrochenes Englisch reden musst,
aber die geben sich meistens Mühe,
weil letztendlich wollen die einen guten Eindruck machen,
und die können es genauso schlecht wie ich.
Ich meine sicherlich nicht die Empörten von Twitter,
sondern halt Leute, die ich nur übers Internet kenne.
Gaming-PC mit PS5-Chips auf Otto bestellt.
Was?
Ich kann...
Okay, okay.
Können wir, können wir machen.
Aber der Titel ist,
der Titel riecht schon ein bisschen nach G-Bait.
Mal gucken.
Die beste Story ist immer noch,
als ein Kind vor den Fortnite-Stadt gekackt hat.
Moment, war das dieses Jahr oder irgendwann mal?
Also das Einzige, was ich dieses Jahr von der Gamescom mitgekriegt hat,
ist das Haft-, äh, nicht Haftbefehl,
wie komm...
Tanzverbot, wie komm ich auf Haftbefehl, Alter?
Äh, dass Tanzverbot irgendeinem aufs Maul gehauen hat.
Oder es versucht hat.
Und die sich irgendwie gekloppt haben.
Dass, äh, dass sich Tanzverbot mit irgendeinem gekloppt hat auf der Gamescom,
hab ich mitgekriegt dieses Jahr.
Ja, und bei den Fortnite-Kindern wundert mich nix.
Wie gesagt, eines der cringigsten Sachen, die ich mal in echt gesehen hab,
waren so eine Gruppe Fortnite-Kinder am Südbahnhof,
die, ähm, vor die Straßenbahn sich gestellt haben
und dann auf den Gleisen der Straßenbahn den Loserdance gemacht haben,
Richtung Fahrerkabine.
Das war, das war so cringe und Fremdschämen,
als ich die gesehen hab.
Da halt konnt ich...
Wisst ihr, ich konnte gar nicht richtig hingucken, so cringe war das.
Cringe.
Ja.
Okay, okay.
Ich hab die News dazu gefunden, Sekunde.
Gamescom-Besucher kackt vor Fortnite-Stand.
Ah, das ist mal fake.
Das stimmt anscheinend gar nicht.
Drauf geschissen, ja.
Leider nur ein Gerücht.
Ja, ich find's auch lustig, wenn das echt wär.
Wobei, ich weiß aus eigener Erfahrung,
wenn's drückt, dann drückt's, ja.
Hatt ich nicht dazu mal sogar...
Äh.
Also, ich weiß noch, wo ich mal in Hanau aufs Klo musste,
weil's so dringend war,
und dann kein Klo gab in Hanau am Hauptbahnhof,
und ich dann auf den Vorplatz zu so nem...
kleinen Häuschen musste, Geld reinschmeißen,
und da ging das Häuschen nicht auf,
und auf dem Display stand drauf,
BOOTING.
Und da musste ich wirklich nochmal zwei Minuten warten,
und hätt mir fast in die Hose gemacht, bis das Klo gebootet ist.
...
Und natürlich war dann am Ende nicht mal Klopapier drinne.
Oh man, das...
Das ist schon ein Unding, wenn du dir überlegst,
dass es an so nem großen Bahnhof wie Hanau kein Klo gibt.
Mittlerweile gibt's ja eins.
Okay, also was soll ich gucken, was ist Scam, das da?
Das überspringen wir jetzt mal kurz.
Skippen wir mal kurz durch.
Gaming-PC mit PS5-Chip auf Otto bestellt.
Das klingt ein bisschen wie die Leute früher in Halo.
Ich geb dir Header.
...
Ich kann dir in den Augen nicht trauen.
Oh.
Ich sag besser gar nichts mehr dazu.
Es ist unzumutbar.
Wobei, der Satz stimmt ja schon.
Aber es liest sich trotzdem irgendwie so...
...
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen bei Hardware Deals.
Es ist wieder so weit.
Es geht weiter mit Hashtag GamingSchrott, eurem Lieblingsformat.
Und wie ihr sehen könnt, hab ich hier wieder was ganz Besonderes für euch organisiert.
Und zwar ist es dieses Mal ein Captiva Gaming-PC.
Den haben die auf Otto gefunden.
Und was hat das mit der PS5 zu tun?
Bzw. den Zuschauer hat uns den auf Instagram gesendet.
Und den fand ich doch ziemlich bemerkenswert, den PC.
Und ich bin mir fast sicher, dass das so ziemlich der, ja, besonderste PC ist.
Abgesehen vielleicht von den Wish-PCs, die wir hier bei dem Format bisher anschauen konnten.
Es wird auf jeden Fall super spannend.
Und ich hätte gesagt, wir packen den PC direkt mal aus.
Moment, was hat das jetzt mit PS5 zu tun?
...
Eine wahre Schönheit.
Was hat das mit der PS5 zu tun?
...
Ich seh jetzt grad...
Der ist jetzt im Angebot.
Ist das die gleiche, die gleiche Grafikkarten-CPU-Kombi, wie aus der PS5, oder wie?
...
Ja.
Es ist die, na ja, also.
Das ist jetzt ja schon ein bisschen weit hergeholt, oder?
...
conqu questa
Ja, komm, also...
...
Ich weiß nicht.
Das liest sich so an, als ist da irgendwie eine halbe PS5 eingebaut oder so.
Gut, man hätte sich denken können, dass es im Endeffekt halt einfach nur die CPU oder wie heißt das Ding, APU Kombi oder sowas ist.
Also, Essential Tools.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, was wir für Essential Tools als Homelaber brauchen.
Zumal, er uns bestimmt wieder seine 20 Kubernetes Cluster erzählt.
My Homelabs.
Ah, Moment, der hat noch was zu seinem Homelab gemacht.
Would I make the same choices?
Nein.
Ganz ehrlich, nein.
Niemand, der noch halbwegs bei Verstand ist, baut sich so einen Homelab auf.
Nicht wegen der Hardware, da sage ich gar nichts dagegen.
Aber wozu braucht man daheim drei Kubernetes Cluster, zwei Rancher OS Instanzen und was auch immer der Typ nicht noch alles hat.
Also, das ist einfach totaler sinnloser Overkill, wo du dich quasi 24-7 um dein Setup kümmern kannst.
Und wohlgemerkt.
Dass das Setup läuft und dass das Setup das macht, was es soll.
Nicht um das, was da drauf läuft.
Er wollte mehr Container als das neue Battlefield, genau.
So sieht's aus.
Zumindest hat er eine schöne USV.
Was ist das für eine?
Powerline?
Ne, nicht Powerline.
Cyber Power?
Ne.
Was ist das für eine?
Sieht man das?
Das ist völlig anders.
Ich baue mein Homelab von der Grunde her auf, das begann mit ein paar USB-C's, mit ein paar Netzwerken, zu einem kleinen Server.
Da stehen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ich weiß nicht warum, die Amis stehen total auf diese Holzboards, wo die Sachen dran gemountet sind.
Sowas habe ich bei uns noch nicht gesehen.
Ich habe sowas, ich habe sowas für die Werkzeuge.
Ich habe ja so eine Werkzeugwand, wo man Werkzeuge dranhängen kann, das ein bisschen so in die Richtung geht.
... zu einem kleinen Server.
... mit Enterprise Servers.
Wenn ich die Chance habe, ein paar Änderungen zu machen, oder sogar Teile davon zu entfernen, würde ich das?
Ja, zum Beispiel drei Kubernetes Cluster abschalten.
Und ich denke die Antwort ist ...
... vielleicht.
Würde ich den selben Server-Rack wählen, oder sogar den ganzen Rack entfernen?
Bin ich glücklich mit meinem Patch-Panel, und der Wahl, Keystones zu verwenden?
Weil optisch ist das schon hübsch gemacht, was er da gebaut hat.
Beleuchtung da oben drauf, mit LED-Leisten, braucht natürlich kein Mensch, aber optisch sieht's natürlich gut aus.
... ist das schon hübsch gemacht, was er da gebaut hat. Beleuchtung da oben drauf, mit LED-Leisten braucht natürlich kein Mensch, aber optisch sieht's natürlich gut aus.
Also ich hab unten im Keller das Unity ... äh, Louie, unten im Keller hängt mein Unity-Media-Zeug an so einem ...
... Perfboard, oder wie das heißt, dran.
Nee, nee, nee, das mein ich nicht. Ähm, wie heißen denn diese Dinger?
Also, warte mal hier.
Nicht Rechenzentrum, Rechen ... ja ...
... Serverraum.
Hier, das was man da im Hintergrund sieht.
Hier, das was ... Lochblech, ja genau, sowas, was man im Hintergrund sieht.
Sowas hab ich auch im Keller, da hängt das Unity-Media-Zeug.
Ja, man kann das schon machen, aber Technik würd ich da halt nicht dranhängen.
Ah, hier sieht man's besser. Hier sieht man's besser.
Der erst mal ... der erst mal der Werkzeug-Flex ...
... Teppichboden schon losgeworden, nee, warum? Warum soll ich den Teppichboden rausmachen?
Erst mal der Werkzeug-Flex, der muss sein.
Ja, und so.
Im Prinzip sieht's übrigens immer noch genauso aus, ich hab hier oben noch eine zweite Box drauf, bisschen mehr Storage.
Ähm ...
... und im Prinzip ist es sonst mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Naja, mal gucken.
... wiring it myself.
Would I choose the same networking equipment, including my gate ...
Nee, nicht im Schaltschrank. Im Schaltschrank nicht.
Das hängt einfach unten an der Wand, weil sie sonst nicht wussten, wo sie's hinmachen sollen.
... gateway, firewall, and even my PoE-Switch.
... and my ...
Das UniFi-Zeug kommt mir nicht mehr ins Haus, ich bin froh, dass es weg ist.
... happy with my One-U servers, the CPUs, the RAMs, and even the disks.
... and there are some who ask if converting an old PC into a ...
Das ist exakt das gleiche Gehäuse, was ich auch früher hatte. Guckt mal, das ist das hier.
Ein Chen- ... das da. Guckt hier unten, da liegt's noch.
Das ist genau das gleiche Gehäuse, man sieht's jetzt von vorne nicht. Ein Chen-Pro-Case.
... äh ...
Every home labber-
Wait a minute.
Yeah.
... a server, and putting it into a rack is worth it.
I guess I've got my work cut out for me, either defending all of my choices, or you, learning from my mistakes.
Before we get started, I just wanted to give a h**ty tale.
So.
If I could change anything about my homeland, would I?
If I could start it all over, what would I choose?
Would I keep each of these items in my rack, or rid of it?
Ja, aufkommen zum Punkt.
I've gotten some criticism from this patch panel, and many have asked ...
Wieso, das ist doch ...
Ich meine, die Kabel sind ein bisschen sehr dünn, aber nicht, dass es problematisch wäre.
Normalerweise sind die halt einfach nur ein bisschen dicker, aber ...
Oder vielleicht sieht's auch einfach nur so aus.
Das macht aber nix.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil daran, dass ...
Ähm, nicht an den Kabeln selbst, sondern an Folie drumherum und Schielding drumherum und was auch immer.
Dass man das halt besonders kompakt gemacht hat, aber ...
Das sieht doch okay aus, was stört die Leute da dran?
Why didn't I crimp all of my own wires?
Das hat doch nicht wirklich jemand gefragt, oder?
Also ganz im Ernst, wer wirklich fragt, warum er nicht seine Kabel selber crimpt, der hat noch nie Kabel selber gekrimpt.
Weil Kabel crimpen sucked.
Das ist so ziemlich ...
Die ...
Eines der beschissensten Tätigkeiten, ...
... die es gibt, Kabel crimpen.
Warum sollte ich, wenn ich die Wahl habe, zwischen Kaufen und Kabel crimpen, warum sollte ich selbst Kabel crimpen?
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, da mag das sinnvoll sein, ja?
Zum Beispiel, wenn du solche Keystone-Dosen hast, wo du dann allerdings nicht crimpen musst, im klassischen Sinn, sondern im Endeffekt ...
... äh, wo du im Endeffekt das Kabel quasi, ich nenn's mal, auflegen musst und dann zusammenklappen.
Ja, guck, wo du das so rein ...
Wo du das so rein, reinfädeln musst und dann klappst das zusammen.
Das kann schon, das kann schon Sinn machen.
Das kann schon Sinn machen, weil diese Dosen sind halt cool.
Da hast du dann halt ne Dose mit den passenden Steckern direkt an der Wand.
Ähm, das ist, das ist okay, das kann man machen, aber für so nen, für so nen Panel hier würd ich im Leben doch nicht ...
Zumal hinten hat das wahrscheinlich, musstest es eh selbst auflegen.
Ne, also, Kabel, Kabel crimpen ist abartig.
Ähm, vor allem ist es billiger.
Ja, gut, möglich, aber ich mein, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Kabel teuer sind.
Also, ja, wahrscheinlich sparst du wirklich was.
Ähm, aber das sind dann wahrscheinlich ...
Ich, ich sag jetzt einfach was, keine Ahnung.
Normales Kabel koste ich 2,50.
Ähm, selbst crimpen koste ich dann 2,10 Euro.
Aber du musst es halt machen.
Und du brauchst auch das ganze Zeug.
Also, insofern, und außerdem ist selbst crimpen abartig.
Ich musste das früher mal ...
Ja.
Und das ist schon wirklich lange her.
Da mussten wir mal in der Schule in Offenbach, also eine Schule in Offenbach, mussten wir mal von, also mehrere Klassenzimmer, die Stecker crimpen.
Das war noch so, noch zu, noch zu Provider-Zeiten und davor.
Das war halt in der Schule in Offenbach.
Da wurden Kabel gelegt von, von mehreren Klassenzimmern zu, zu und zu und zu.
Und da musste man sich auf so eine Leiter, muss man sich auf eine Leiter stellen.
Die kamen rechts oben halt aus der, zwischen den Räumen raus.
Nicht aus der Decke, sondern halt aus so einem Loch zwischen den Räumen.
Und da mussten wir da Stecker drauf crimpen.
Da standen wir auf der, auf der Leiter und haben einen halben Tag Stecker gekrimpt, Leute.
Das ist einfach nur Kacke.
Das willst du nicht machen.
Warum?
Ja, so teuer sind die Krimpzangen gar nicht.
Es gibt billige China-Chinesen-Krimpzangen, so ein Set für, was weiß ich, 20 Euro.
Damit willst du natürlich jetzt nicht am Tag 300 Kabel machen.
Aber für daheim reicht's.
Hält mir grad ein, mein Nachbar hat immer noch mein Auflege- und Krimpset.
Und meine Keystone-Dosen und Sachen, die ich übrig hatte.
Weil er mich gefragt hat, ob er das haben kann, weil er verkabeln will bei sich.
Das ist aber auch schon wieder ein Jahr her.
Ey.
Da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Das ist einfach abartig.
Ich meine, vielleicht gibt's da mittlerweile bessere Möglichkeiten.
Also, zu der, zu der Zeit, wo ich das gemacht hab, war das wirklich noch Kabel abisolieren, ähm,
Geflechte, Zeug, dieses, dieses verflechtete, dieses, dieses Draht-Zeug, dieses Drahtgeflecht rum,
hinterstülpen, ähm, reinfädeln in diese, in dieses Plastik-Ding,
diese, mit dieser Einfädel-Hilfe in Stecker reinmachen.
Festkrimpen.
Zeug wieder vorziehen, abschneiden.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob's das dann war.
Das war eklig.
Ja. Korrekt.
Beste, beste Entscheidung überhaupt.
Selber krimpen ist einfach nur...
Ja, und danach testen, dass es geht.
...testen, dass es geht.
Hab ich übrigens bei mir in meinem Rack auch so.
Also, ich, ich hab auch solche, ich hab, ich hab ja gar kein Patch-Panel, in dem Sinne, ich hab so eine Keystone-Leiste,
wo du verschiedenste Sachen reinclipsen kannst, von AJ45-Steckern bis USB-Stecker und sonst was.
Für kleine Installationen ist das viel besser.
Find ich, ja, deswegen hatte ich, hatte ich so gemacht.
Und, ähm, hier hast du einfach viel stressfreier.
...anytime soon, so I'm giving this a keep.
Do I regret choosing my UDM Pro as my gateway and firewall?
Ja.
Absolutely not.
This appliance has...
...kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
...been great, except for the occasional bugs with firmware.
It's been working out nicely.
I even started using UniFi Protect Camera System, along with adding a lot of cameras.
Now, for my gripes.
As you can see, I have uplinked this to my Switch-Viewer.
It could be a 10-gig DAC.
And you can see I have a 10-gig WAN-Port here.
However, nothing is attached.
I really wish UniFi would let me reassign this to a LAN-Port, so I could have another 10-gig port.
And that would save me from buying a 10-gig Switch.
Which is probably why they're not gonna do it.
One of my other complaints was the lack of VPN-options.
However, they've just recently added support for a new VPN they call Teleport,
which is actually WireGuard.
So it's really awesome.
Heißt aber anders.
Wenn man nicht will, dass es so heißt, wie es eigentlich heißt, oder wie.
Ich hab mein UniFi-Zeug rausgeschmissen.
Gut, ich hatte auch keine Tree Machine und keinen Router-Switch-Gedöns.
Also, was ich noch habe von Ubiquiti ist mein Switch.
Das ist allerdings ein ES16XG.
Heißt das Ding so? ES16XG?
Das ist kein UniFi-Switch, das ist ein Edge-Switch.
Also, was mit ganz normalem Web-Interface das ist.
Alter, der wird ja immer teurer.
Ich hab den mal für 500 Euro gekauft.
Und sogar im Angebot vielleicht 4 Neues.
Der ist die letzten Jahre.
Ich hab den jetzt auch schon 4, 5 Jahre.
Das musst du erst mal schaffen, dass eine Hardware in 5 Jahren einfach 20% teurer wird.
Warum ich den gekauft habe, ist im Prinzip ganz einfach.
Du hast 12 Ports SFP Plus und 4 Ports Kupfer 10 Gigabit.
Das gab es damals in keiner anderen Kombination und gibt es heute auch wenig.
Wo sind wir denn?
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ah Leute, ich hab zu viel Zeug auf.
Hier.
Da reichen die Helds der Rauch der Verkäufer vor.
Und hier ist, warum.
Für circa eine halbe Menge kann man den Switch 16PoE kaufen, welcher mir 16 Ports geben würde, nur nur eine halbe sind PoE.
Aber wahrscheinlich genug, um meine PoE-Anbieter zu verwenden.
Man könnte sich einfach einen billigen Mikrotik PoE-Switch kaufen oder so was.
Weil die meisten PoE-Geräte brauchen ja noch nicht mal einen G eigentlich.
Aber okay, unter einem Gigabit würde ich ihn nicht machen.
Die andere Anfrage zu diesem Switch ist, dass du nur zwei 1Gig SFP-Ports bekommst.
Na, SFP ist doch unsinnig, wenn schon muss es SFP Plus sein, ansonsten kannst du auch
ein ganz normales Kupferkabel mit EJ45 nehmen, wenn es nur Gigabit sein soll.
Ganz ehrlich, ich brauche keinen 10 Gigabit Uplink für einen PoE Switch, weil an PoE
Switche kommen Kameras dran oder was weiß ich, was macht man an PoE Switch noch großartig
dran außer Kameras?
Access Points, ja, hatte ich noch dran.
Telefone, das ist aber, das ist alles, okay, das ist alles, das ist alles, das ist alles
Okay, ja, okay, du brauchst einen 10 Gigabit Uplink, das lasse ich mir gefallen, wenn du
48 Gigabit Geräte dran hast, dann willst du vielleicht einen 10 Gigabit Uplink, okay.
Aber wir reden hier von einer Verkabelung daheim, da hast du realistisch betrachtet,
was hast du daheim dran?
Ja, zwei bis vier Kameras, vielleicht ein Telefon, vielleicht, wenn man sowas daheim
hat und eins bis drei Access Points.
Fertig, ist jetzt nicht so, als kommt man damit irgendwie an die Grenze daheim und deswegen
würde ich mir einfach einen ganz billigen PoE Switch kaufen, der muss noch nicht mal
großartig managt sein, wobei durchaus seine Vorteile hat, wenn man ein paar Sachen über
das Webinterface einstellen kann und gut ist, gut, ich meine, vielleicht betreibt er
seine Kubernetes Cluster über PoE, man weiß ja nicht.
Das gibt mir vier in total, also, wenn ich es wieder alles wieder machen musste, würde
ich mit diesem gehen.
Wenn du überhaupt denkst, dass du mehr als 24 Gigabit Ports und mehr als zwei 10 Gigabit
Ports brauchst, würde ich mir ein bisschen kaufen, um dich ein bisschen zukünftig zu prüfen,
also behalte es oder verbessere es, naja, wenn ich nicht so schnell ausbreiten musste,
würde ich es definitiv behalten, aber so viel wie ich es nicht tue, gebe ich es ein
verbessert, das hoch oder runter, ich gehe runter, wegen dessen, wie schnell ich ausbreite,
neben meinem Paar Super Microservern.
Upgraden ist dauernd.
Der One-U-Form-Faktor.
Oh, guck mal, das ist noch USB 1.1 oder sowas, ah ne, USB 2, ja, gut, zu dem Server Setup
habe ich mich ja schon mal ausgelassen, ich finde, das ist maßloser Overkill, im Endeffekt
für das, was er machen will, ja, okay, ich verstehe bloß nicht, warum er es machen will.
Und andere Kompromisse.
Haha.
Der hat Kubernetes-Cluster, ESX-Cluster, ich weiß nicht, was er damit daheim macht, das
konnte er uns, also das hat er in keinem Video bis jetzt erklärt, was er damit macht, also
er hat es erklärt, aber nichts davon ergab jetzt Sinn, warum er, sag mal, ist der RAM-Chepp?
Ah ne, das soll so sein, ne.
Nichts davon ergab irgendwie Sinn, warum man so viel braucht, der hat im Prinzip locker
die Hälfte der Sachen, die darauf läuft.
Um sich selbst zu verwalten, und der Rest sind dann so Standardsachen, das ist mal
ein Home Assistant gewesen, mal ein Wiki gewesen, mal irgendwie, nichts Wildes, ja.
Und mit mindestens vier Geräten für Geräte, ich glaube, ich habe alles bekommen, was ich
aus diesen Servern wollte, nein, es hat keine Dual-Sockets, aber ich habe mich mehr um
Effizienz geäußert als um mehr Koren, also ein Socket ist gut.
Es gibt...
immer weniger Dual-Socket-Server, weil es halt CPUs gibt mit was weiß ich wie viele
Kernen.
Ja, RAM ist billig.
RAM ist das Einzige, was gerade günstig ist.
RAM ist billig.
Wenn ihr euch fragt, was ihr euch für einen 10-Gigabit-Switch kaufen wollt, ja, zeige ich
euch jetzt mal ein.
Ihr braucht einen Mikro-Tick, SFP plus, ähm, vier, ne, das ist somit der günstigste SFP
Plus.
Alter, die sind auch teuer geworden, ich glaube, ich habe meinen, das muss ich mal kurz, Leute,
ich muss mal kurz auf dem Handy, äh, ich habe mein Handy nicht hier, ich muss mal kurz gucken,
was ich dafür bezahlt habe, ich bilde mir ein, ich habe damals sogar nur an die 100
Euro dafür bezahlt, warum ist das alles so teuer geworden?
Moment, ich hoffe, ich habe es bei Amazon gekauft, sonst finde ich es nicht mehr, ja,
Mikro-Tick, ne, das kann ich euch nicht sagen, ist nicht bei Amazon drin.
Naja, ähm, also erst mal kurz...
Ja.
Der ist gut, der ist, der ist, der ist gut, ich meine, SFP plus, das ist, das ist, äh,
natürlich kein PoE, logischerweise, weil PoE über Glasfaser geht in der Regel relativ
schlecht, es können auch Direct Attached Kupferkabel sein, aber über SFP plus machst
du kein PoE, aber wenn man einfach nur, wenn man einfach nur einen, einen 10, 10G-Switch
haben will, ist der wirklich gut, also wohlgemerkt für SFP plus Karten, ja gut, das ist halt,
das ist halt Vor- und Nachteil zugleich, du kannst damit viel machen.
Aber man muss sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen.
Samsung.
Ja.
Das gibt mir nur eine halbe Kapazität, also bekomme ich nur ca. 2TB usabler Raum.
Das klingt wie viel, aber wenn du 10-15 Virtual Machines auf jedem Server hast,
funktioniert das sehr schnell.
Ich bin auch froh mit der effizienten...
...zum Verwalten der ganzen Sache.
Ja, also...
Das kann man machen, weil man es cool findet, aber sinnvoll ist es nicht.
Ich würde meinen Rechner überhaupt nicht ins Rack einbauen wollen.
Mein Rechner soll neben mir stehen am Schreibtisch.
Warum sollte der hier hinter mir in der Abstellkammer stehen?
Chat.
Frage an den Chat.
Bin mir sicher...
Sekunde.
Mein Chat, bin mir sicher, dass man mir hier weiterhelfen kann.
Strebe derzeit einen Jobwechsel an.
Aha.
Habt ihr einen Vortrag?
In welchem Bereich man als Quereinsteiger reinkommen könnte?
Naja, es kommt drauf an, was du kannst.
Beziehungsweise, was du für Vorkenntnisse hast.
Das kann man jetzt so pauschal...
Das ist schwierig zu sagen, ja.
Ja, man muss halt sagen, gerade IT-technisch ist es so,
man kann da als Quereinsteiger, denke ich, durchaus einsteigen.
Aber es ist halt ein Unterschied.
Man muss sagen, die Business-Technik-Welt sieht schon ein bisschen anders aus,
als was man privat so kennt.
Selbst, wenn man sich mit den Technologien auskennt.
Und die andere Frage ist, wie alt du bist.
Vielleicht kannst du eine Physie-Ausbildung machen.
Man kann eine Physie-Ausbildung theoretisch auch mit 60 machen,
aber wahrscheinlich will man das dann nicht.
Vielleicht kannst du auch eine Physie...
Wie heißt das?
So eine Physie-Schnell-Überholspur-Ausbildung machen,
wenn du schon Vorkenntnisse hast und schon einen Beruf gelernt hast.
Also, sag mal, so das Enterprise-Umfeld oder so das Business-Umfeld zu kennen,
IT-technisch, finde ich persönlich nicht verkehrt.
Ähm...
Einfach, weil es ein Unterschied ist, ob du daheim warst,
im Business-Business-Bastel oder im Business-Umfeld.
Im Business-Umfeld spielen so viele andere Sachen eine Rolle,
die nicht unbedingt rein...
Na klar gibt es Fachinformatiker, System-Integration noch.
Ähm...
Wo man daheim halt nicht hat.
Hast du es auch schon ausprobiert?
Chain-Lore?
Wobei...
Wahrscheinlich gibt es deine Bilder schon überall auf 4chan und sonst wo.
Chain-Lore 69.
Jobbörse, Twitch site, ja.
Das...
Auch wenn da Keck dahinter steht, ist das nicht so.
Irgendwie...
Irgendwie könnte ich es mir bei dir sogar gut vorstellen.
Chain-Lore-Privat 69.
Ja...
Shugga...
Shugga-Daddy...
Ne, wie heißt...
Sugga...
Ne.
Ne, nicht...
Nicht Sugga-Daddy.
Shugga...
Shugga-Daddy.
Chain-Lore-Shugga-Daddy 69.
Shugga.
Hast du eine Idee für einen gescheiten KVM-Switch unter 500€?
Ähm...
Du willst...
Du willst wirklich einen KVM-Switch.
Du willst keinen...
Remote...
...Bedienen vom Rechner haben, oder?
Also willst du wirklich Tastatur und Maus und sowas umschalten?
Ne, da kenne ich keinen.
Wenn du Remote...
Wenn du so einen Remote-KVM suchst...
Da kann ich dir was erzählen.
Da gibt es ganz günstig oftmals bei Ebay.
Aber das suchst du ja nicht.
Du suchst ja wirklich was zum Umschalten von einem Rechner an anderen.
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Also es gibt jetzt soweit ich weiß genau...
Es gibt...
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration...
Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung...
Und was gibt es jetzt noch Neues?
Fachinformatiker Daten...
...Auswertung oder irgendwie sowas?
Wie heißen die anderen zwei?
Und Netzwerk irgendwie?
Datenverarbeitung, ja.
Was andere?
Daten- und Prozessanalyse, ja.
Also die Udemy-Kurse sind wirklich nicht schlecht.
Muss man sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwo...
Wo...
Wo denn was hier?
Also...
Äh...
Die Udemy-Kurse sind nicht schlecht.
Aber das ist das, was ich meine.
Also...
Die...
Die Sache, das privat ein bisschen zu üben und so...
So das Enterprise-Umfeld...
Das ist dann schon ein bisschen anders.
Du...
Also gerade wenn es...
Wenn es ums Programmieren geht.
Du musst ja dann zum Beispiel nicht nur die Programmiersprache sicher beherrschen.
Wobei das würde ich sagen noch nicht mal so...
Das aller relevanteste ist, dass du alles aus dem Kopf kannst.
Denn du musst halt wissen, nach was du suchen musst.
Ich meine, ich mache seit...
Ich mache C-Sharp auch seit...
Seit 15, 20 Jahren fast schon jetzt mittlerweile.
Seit 2003 oder so.
Ähm...
Und ich kann trotzdem nicht die Standard-Library auswendig.
Aber ich weiß dann, was ich suchen muss.
Aber trotzdem...
Du musst dann beispielsweise Umgang mit Git gut drauf haben.
Du musst wissen, wie man Pull-Requests macht.
Wie man Merge-Requests macht.
Wie man mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeitet.
Äh...
Wie man ein Code-Review macht.
Beziehungsweise wie man die Sachen dafür vorbereitet, dass das ordentlich gemerged werden kann.
Dann eventuell...
Bisschen Ahnung haben, so nach dem Motto...
Okay, wie sehen die Style-Guides dort aus?
Dass man mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeiten kann.
Ähm...
Wie wird das im...
Ganz im Endeffekt deployed?
Wie ist die Pipeline dahinter?
Also...
Da musst du im Enterprise-Umfeld schon ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung haben, als einfach nur...
Einen Udemy-Kurs haben.
Aber ich meine, gut...
Kann durchaus sein, dass dir irgendwie einer als Einsteiger, wenn du es übelst drauf hast, da trotzdem eine Chance gibt.
Ähm...
Rein durch den Udemy-Kurs...
Ich weiß nicht, also...
Stell ich mir ein bisschen schwierig vor.
Danke für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Hyper-Subscriber!
Selbst wenn du 5 Udemy-Kurse gemacht hast...
So ein bisschen...
So ein bisschen Enterprise...
So ein bisschen Enterprise-Business-Erfahrung ist halt nicht verkehrt.
Und das ist das, was man halt in der Ausbildung lernt.
Ich meine, du kannst doch dein eigenes Startup gründen.
Was geiles Programmieren.
Und das dann verkaufen nach 3 Jahren.
Und Big Strongs machen.
Aber...
Die Chancen sind wahrscheinlich nicht so hoch.
Das ist halt auch, finde ich, eines der wichtigsten Sachen, die man in der Ausbildung lernen muss.
Es ist gerade im IT-Business- und Enterprise-Umfeld...
Gar nicht mal so sehr alles eine Frage der Technik.
Sondern es werden teilweise unglaublich dumme Entscheidungen...
Getroffen.
Absichtlich.
Und das ist auch so.
Damit muss man erstmal klar kommen.
Wo man sich denkt, das würde ich privat im Leben nicht so machen.
Wird das dort absichtlich so dumm gemacht.
Klar, kannst du.
Er schreibt mir momentan in der Ausbildung zum FISI.
Ich habe festgestellt, dass ich das mit Programmieren am meisten Spaß mache.
Kann man auch FISI eher...
Ja, kannst du.
Es kommt ganz auf den Betrieb an, wo du bist.
Gut, nachdem du jetzt wo angefangen hast als FISI...
Bist du wahrscheinlich eher so im...
Was weiß ich...
Im Admin-Bereich.
Vermutlich.
Ja.
Vielleicht seid ihr auch schon modern.
Und ihr macht...
Ihr professioniert irgendwelche Cloud-Kisten oder so.
Aber in der Regel...
Sag mal, wenn einer FISI sucht, ist das eher so ganz grob so in der...
In der Admin-Richtung.
Und wenn einer halt Anwendungsentwickler sucht, ist das halt eher Software-Entwicklung.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass du das eine oder das andere machen musst.
Ganz ehrlich, das liegt mittlerweile so nah beieinander.
Und ich bin der Meinung, ein guter Entwickler muss heute auch Ahnung haben von...
Wie das betrieben wird.
Und ein guter FISI beziehungsweise Admin oder...
Was weiß ich...
Cloud...
DevOps-Mensch, was auch immer.
Der muss auch Ahnung davon haben, wie man was programmiert beziehungsweise wie die Anwendung...
Wie die Anwendung letztendlich funktioniert, die betrieben wird.
Also, da gibt's viele Überschneidungen.
Und wenn ihr FISI...
Wenn ihr Programmieren am meisten Spaß macht...
Bei uns ist es beispielsweise so...
Die Azubis können irgendwie Punkte vergeben, wo sie hinwollen abteilungstechnisch.
Dann wird das versucht zu berücksichtigen.
Und wenn du gutes Know-How aufgebaut hast in der Ausbildung...
Kannst du dich danach...
Was übrigens nie verkehrt ist, es ist ein guter GitHub-Account mit Projekten drin.
Äh...
Kannst du es ruhig probieren, dich da zu bewerben.
Und wenn du...
Wichtig ist halt...
Unterm Strich, ganz ehrlich...
Wichtig ist, dass du es kannst.
Das kann man nicht oft genug sagen.
Ja, in Deutschland ist es natürlich immer noch wichtig, dass du halt irgendwas vorzuweisen hast.
Aber irgendwo dran muss man es hinweisen.
Irgendwo dran muss man es ja ein bisschen festmachen.
Aber unterm Strich kommt es darauf an, dass du halt das kannst, was dort gebraucht wird.
Du kannst noch so...
Es gibt Leute, die können wahnsinnig gut schwätzen.
Und du denkst, du hast hier den Ultra-Experte schlechthin vor dir stehen.
Und dann soll er eine Sache machen und du denkst dir...
Alter, was treibt der da?
Habe ich schon so oft bei irgendwelchen Highly Paid Consultants bei uns auf der Arbeit gesehen.
Die kauen dir das Ohr ab.
Was für geile High-IQ-Fivehead-Sachen sie schon gemacht haben.
Und dann denkst du dir so nach dem Motto...
Alter, lock dich mal per SSH ein.
Die einfachsten Sachen klappen nicht richtig.
Wo ich mir dann auch immer denke...
Zwischen Erzählen und Machen sind oftmals schon wirklich Welten dazwischen.
Also wir hatten schon super krasse Highly Paid Consultant Professionals,
die mit so simplen Sachen wie einem SCP von einer Kiste auf die andere Probleme hatten.
Wo ich mir dann denke...
Alter...
Zu was soll ich dich denn konsultieren, wenn auch nicht immer das funktioniert?
Mein Consultant heißt ja im Prinzip im Wort schon...
Ich frage den im Fall der Fälle, dass ich selbst nicht weiter weiß.
Konsultiere ich den.
Und ich wüsste nicht, wozu ich den konsultieren sollte.
Aber wir hatten auch schon solche Leute, wo ich mir wirklich gedacht habe...
Meine Güte, was ist da los?
Oder Leute, die 2022 es nicht schaffen, ein Merch-Request aufzumachen.
Oder ein Pull-Request, je nachdem was man...
Oder...
Die es noch nicht mal schaffen, ein Git-Repo zu kreieren.
Oder Leute, die 2022 es nicht schaffen, ein Merch-Request aufzumachen.
Oder Leute, die 2022 es nicht schaffen, ein Git-Repo zu kreieren.
Windows-Click-Admin sollte heute mal zumindest ein Git-Repo klonen können.
Es gibt so ein paar Basics, die würde ich einfach erwarten, dass man die kann.
Übergreifend, IT-technisch.
Und wenn du es kannst, dann kannst du auch programmieren.
Kannst du auch später in der Richtung arbeiten.
Hat jemand eine Essensempfehlung am Frankfurter Bahnhof?
Ja.
In welcher Richtung soll es denn sein, was zu essen?
Also, das Problem ist, ich kenne mich da nicht mehr so gut aus, weil ich jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre Homeoffice hatte und ich weiß, was es davor noch gibt.
Den Burgerladen gibt es nicht mehr, das weiß ich.
Ich überlege gerade.
Also direkt am Hauptbahnhof ist eh kacke, du musst ein bisschen in die Seitenstraßen.
Und wohlgemerkt, Leute, eine Sache muss ich jetzt...
Nicht, dass du gleich irgendwie den Kulturschlock deines Lebens erlebst.
Also, hier vorne ist ja der Haupteingang.
Sekunde, so.
Leute, wie konnte man Google Maps nochmal auf 3D schalten?
Wisst ihr, wie das geht?
Oder muss ich direkt Google Earth?
Okay.
Den Typen ziehen?
Nee, das ist Street View.
Das ist Street View von 2008.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das meine ich nicht.
Ähm.
Also, dann gehen wir mal zu Google Earth.
Also, pass mal auf.
Nicht, dass du jetzt gleich, wie gesagt, den Kulturschock deines Lebens erlebst.
Im Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
So.
Also.
Sieht das nicht schick aus mittlerweile hier?
So, also, hier gehst du ja raus.
Hier kommst du raus.
Das ist der Haupteingang.
Hier hinten gehst du besser nicht lang.
Nidderstraße.
Nidderstraße ist, ähm, ja, Drogenausgabestelle und, also, da sind auch diese ganzen Suchtprogrammausgabenstellen und sonst was.
Kann man nicht hier die Straße...
Kann man nicht die Straßen irgendwie einblenden lassen?
Straßennamen, geht das irgendwie?
Kennt sich, kennt sich damit jemand aus?
Mit Straßennamen einblenden lassen.
Also, das hier müsste die Kaiserstraße sein.
Das hier müsste die Kaiserstraße sein.
Das hier müsste die Münchner Straße sein.
Also, Kaiserstraße kannst du laufen.
Das ist da, wo früher die ganzen Puffs waren, aber jetzt sind da eigentlich bloß noch Supermärkte, Restaurants und Friseure und sowas.
Und Friseure und sowas.
Ja, Kaiserstraße, alles klar.
Also, hier kannst du raus.
Hier würde ich nicht rein.
Taunusstraße.
Nidderstraße.
Was hier unten ist, ist Penner und Assi-Ecke.
Also, hier würde ich nicht lang.
Hier ist gut.
Hier kannst du...
Hier kannst du lang.
Kaiserstraße ist okay.
So.
Da hast du halt drei Milliarden Restaurants.
Ich kann dir ehrlich gesagt gar nichts mehr großartig...
Also, hier war ich öfters mal mexikanisch futtern.
Das ist jetzt aber nicht sonderlich geil.
Das ist einfach nur nah.
Zeit für Brot.
Nee.
Guck lieber bei irgendeinem Empfehlungsguide.
Zumindest da kannst du raus.
Das ist gut.
Da passiert nichts.
Okay, gucken wir uns das Video mal fertig an.
Jetzt habe ich die Hälfte bestimmt übersehen.
Also, hatten wir das?
Ähm...
C Sharp gibt es schon lange, ja.
Ja, manchmal bin ich auch überrascht, wie tief da manchmal die Anforderungen sind.
Ist halt Windows, ja.
Was hältst du von AWS Cloud-Zertifizierungen?
Ich habe von AWS nicht viel Plan.
Also, ich hätte die Möglichkeit, die Azure-Prüfung zu machen.
Ich sage jetzt die, es gibt nicht eine.
Ich weiß nicht genau, welches es ist, weil es mich nie interessiert hat.
Aber habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, das kann sinnvoll sein.
Nicht wirklich, weil ich denke, man ist danach besser.
Sondern, weil Cloud-Zertifizierungen...
Cloud-Zertifizierungen tatsächlich, finde ich persönlich jetzt, ja, eines der Zertifizierungen
sind, wo noch ein bisschen drauf geguckt wird.
Gerade, weil es was Neues ist und weil es sehr unübersichtlich ist.
Also, wenn du jemanden hast, der nachweislich in Azure navigieren kann und weiß, wo was
ist, hast du schon mal gewonnen.
Ansonsten, ich persönlich, wie gesagt, ihr wisst, ich bin kein großer Zertifizierungs-Fan.
Kann dir aber, denke ich, schon was bringen.
Tja.
Wir hatten übrigens jetzt auch, muss ich auch mal sagen, wir hatten auch jede Menge
fähiger Consultants, aber so ist es ja nicht.
Aber wir hatten halt auch schon viele, wo ich mich gefragt habe, zu was soll ich den denn
konsultieren?
Ja, die siehst du auch vom Hauptbahnhof.
Geh aus dem Haupteingang raus.
Und nicht unten, unten durch die Unterführung.
Frankfurt, siebtbeste Stadt der Welt, ernsthaft?
Ja gut, Frankfurt an sich ist okay.
Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel sackt halt.
Ich muss euch sagen, ich war noch nicht oft in Berlin.
Ja.
Und ich kann mich daran erinnern, als ich nach Berlin gefahren bin, Hauptbahnhof mit
dem Zug.
Also ich kannte das vorher noch nicht.
Ja.
Und ich bin rausgekommen aus dem Hauptbahnhof und als erstes hat mich irgendein Penner angehustet.
Und ich dachte mir so, ist wieder heim.
Es ist wie in Frankfurt.
Und ganz im Ernst, Berlin, Hauptbahnhof und drumherum.
So ein Unterschied zu Frankfurt merkst du da gar nicht.
Das ist alles relativ ähnlich.
Also wenn du es nicht wüsstest, du könntest auch in Frankfurt sein.
Wien ist, okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Kopenhagen, Kopenhagen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich persönlich würde lieber nach Kopenhagen als nach Wien.
Zürich.
Was?
Calgary, weiß ich nicht, wo das ist.
Vancouver, oh, da reden sie Französisch.
Da würde ich schon mal nicht hin.
Genf, Frank... Ernsthaft? Frankfurt?
Frankfurt ist die siebtlebenswerteste Stadt der Welt.
Frankfurt?
Ja, okay, wegen Banken und internationalem Kram.
Also man muss ja sagen, in der Richtung ja.
Ich meine, Frankfurt ist eine der wenigen Städte, die tatsächlich, also in Deutschland,
die einen festen Einwohner aus jedem Land der Welt haben.
Also dann hast du dann auch sowas wie Trinidad and Tobago oder wie der Kram heißt, irgendwie zwei feste Einwohner.
Frankfurt hat aus jedem, egal noch wie kleinen Land der Welt,
mindestens einen festen Einwohner.
Das liegt aber zum größten Teil an Banken und Versicherungs-Kram und allem möglichen.
Auch vom Vatikan, von allem.
Auch von Nordkorea, von jedem Land.
Mindestens einen.
Aber das wundert mich, dass du so weit umgehst.
Ich meine, Frankfurt hat schon nette, nette, nette Ecken.
So ist das nicht.
Aber das Bahnhofsviertel zählt auf jeden Fall nicht dabei.
Haha.
Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel ist halt einfach nur...
Ja.
Frankfurt, Goethestraße, Louis Vitorstor, zahl die Kollektion bar, Fick auf Sponsor.
Das haben wir sonst noch. Amsterdam, Osaka, Melbourne, alles klar.
Was kommt als nächstes?
Hamburg, Düsseldorf. Hamburg ist 16 und Düsseldorf ist 22.
Hamburg war ich nur zwei, zwei, dreimal.
Ich glaube sogar nur zweimal.
Und da muss ich sagen, Hamburg Hauptbahnhof und die Nebenstraßen waren jetzt auch nicht viel besser als Frankfurt.
München fand ich tatsächlich ganz nice, muss ich sagen.
Zwar auch übelst dreckiger Hauptbahnhof, aber wenn du rauskommst, bist du direkt in der Stadt.
Das fand ich sehr praktisch.
Also bisschen wie in Frankfurt.
Ähm...
München...
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen.
München fand ich tatsächlich ganz nett.
War auch noch nicht oft da.
Und anscheinend bauen die ja den ganzen Tag, das ganze Jahr über Oktoberfest auf.
Ich bin irgendwann im...
Wann war das? Januar?
Irgendwann im Mai oder so war das, glaube ich.
Ich bin irgendwann im Mai langgelaufen, gegenüber von diesem, von diesem Platz, wo dann...
Von diesem Platz, also von diesem Gelände, wo das Oktoberfest ist.
Und da haben die schon aufgebaut.
Also anscheinend ist irgendwie rund, das ganze Jahr über wird Oktoberfest aufgebaut.
Russische Städte rutschen ab.
Ich glaube, ukrainische Städte bestimmt auch.
Aber dass russische Städte abrutschen, das wundert mich nicht.
Wer hätte sich das nur denken können?
Oh Mann.
Ja gut, jetzt wissen wir hier auch Bescheid.
Frankfurt vor München?
Naja gut, aus einem Grund.
In Frankfurt kannst du noch Mittagessen gehen, mit Mittagskarte für 10, 12 Euro.
In München nicht.
Und in der Schweiz schon mal gar nicht.
Dankeschön, 30 Milliarden Bits, pock.
Dankeschön Leute für die Subs.
Äh, nicht für die Subs, für die Bits.
So, durchgescrollt.
Also, jetzt gucken wir das Video mal schnell fertig.
System in a rack with everything else.
Easier for cable management, networking and even battery backup.
I will say though, what you get in convenience in racking, you end up paying for in cable management within the case.
It's kind of a...
Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn, sein normalen Rechner.
Warum sollte ich meinen Desktop-Rechner in ein Rack einbauen? Wo ist der Sinn?
But most of it is my fault, since I've been using it since the past few years.
Da komm ich ja noch nicht mal dran, um ein USB reinzustecken.
But its primary use case is a local backup of all my data. A second local copy, if you will.
Also, this will end up housing some of my video cards, if I ever move Plex out of my 1U-Servers.
And a case like this gives you plenty of height to do that.
So, this is definitely a keeper.
Wer macht denn noch Plex heutzutage?
Disc shelf. Oh, my disc shelf.
I was fortunate enough to pick this up before all the Chia-Farmers wanted this, and I got a really good deal at the time.
Was ist denn das? Ist das irgendein SAS-SAS-Extension-Case, oder?
All the Chia-Farmers wanted this.
Ja, aber 2TB kommst du halt anderweit mit.
Kennst du was Besseres als Plex?
Nee, nee, so war das gar nicht gemein.
Wenn man Anwendungszwecke für Plex hat, ist Plex sicherlich vollkommen okay.
Aber ich fra...
Ich wundere mich, dass so viele Leute Anwendungszwecke für Plex haben.
Ich mein, der einzige realistisch betrachtete Anwendungszweck für Plex ist,
man lädt sich reihenweise oder hat sich vielleicht die letzten Jahre reihenweise Serienfilme runtergeladen
und möchte die mehrfach gucken und will quasi so ein lokales Archiv haben.
Dafür Plex, ja, okay, wenn man sowas hat.
Aber ich hab überhaupt gar keine Filme und so mehr lokal gespeichert,
weil die brauchen einfach massig Speicherplatz und wenn ich was gucken will, mach ich's über irgendeinen Streaming-Anbieter.
Ja, das ganze Zeug braucht massig Strom.
Ja.
Das ganze Zeug braucht massig Strom.
I hate to say it, but I would give this a...
Upgrade it.
Based on how much power it draws and how much space it takes up.
Still really awesome though.
Cases sehen aus aus SAS-Zeiten von Pentium 4.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das auch aus so einer Zeit.
Ich mein, zwei Terabyte.
Das ist ja...
Ja.
Und auch diese Status-Indicator-Sachen hier, die sehen schon wirklich sehr oldschool aus.
Man kann leider anhand der Farbe nicht den Hersteller erkennen.
Normalerweise erkennst du die eigentlich ganz gut.
Zumindest früher hast du es gut erkannt.
IBM war immer schwarz mit ein bisschen blau.
Und früher hatte IBM vorne immer noch so eine Metallkugel drinne.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Vielleicht kennt das noch jemand.
Ähm...
Ne, man sieht's hier nicht.
Vielleicht muss ich mal...
Vielleicht muss ich nach old...
Old...
Old suchen.
Sieht man das hier?
Die hat teilweise so eine rötliche Metallkugel noch drinne.
Ich weiß nicht wozu das da ist.
Wozu die das damals hatten.
Hat der hier eine?
Also IBM hast du zumindest immer erkannt.
Ne.
IBM hast du zumindest immer erkannt.
Die waren immer schwarz und mit ein bisschen blau.
Und auch diese...
Auch die ganzen Sachen.
Und teilweise hier auch diese Wechselrahmen-Dinge und so.
Schwarz und blau.
Dann hattest du HP.
Die waren grau-rot.
Dann hattest du Dell.
Ne, warte mal.
Doch, ne?
HP war grau-rot.
Und Dell ist...
Dell ist eigentlich nur grau.
Oder war Dell grau-rot?
Ach, Moment.
Die Dell 380 waren HP?
Ja klar waren die HP.
Aber die alten...
Die alten waren...
Genau.
Ja okay, das war schwarz-rot.
Und Dell war grau.
So rum.
Ja.
Also du konntest ganz gut immer erkennen, was die Leute in ihren Racks eingebaut haben,
wenn man sich einfach nur so die Front angeguckt hat.
So sieht für mich der klassische HP-Server aus.
So ein Ding.
Ein schwarzer Brocken mit paar roten Elementen.
CD-Laufwerk.
Ihr werdet lachen, Leute.
Die haben heute noch VGA-Ausgänge.
Wie waren die Preise?
Das war damals auch schon teuer.
Unless you find something to put it in.
And then I would say upgrade it.
It's an empty slot.
Next is my UPS.
This Triplight UPS is one of the most affordable UPSs that you can...
Okay.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Kennt ihr den Hersteller Triplight?
Sagt mir gar nichts.
...rack and mount on the market.
It's worked out great for me the last few years and has saved my data and network a few
times.
However, it only gives me 10 minutes of runtime...
Man hat davon abgesehen, das einzige Mal, wo mein Rack wirklich ausgefallen ist, ist,
als die USV verreckt ist.
...shuts down.
Now that's barely enough time...
Ich habe aktuell keine USV mehr.
...safely.
They do sell another model of this that allows you to connect additional batteries.
However, that model was sold out...
Preisqualität.
Ehrlich gesagt, das hat sich alles nicht so viel genommen.
Es war eher die Frage, welcher Sales-Typ deine Einkaufsabteilung am besten beschwätzt
hat.
Also wir hatten lange Zeit fast ausschließlich IBM, weil wir wohl irgendwie gute Business-Kontakte
mit IBM gepflegt haben und dann halt die Sachen halt...
Also eins muss man halt sagen.
Die...
Die Business-Enterprise-Preise, die auf den Webseiten stehen, sind bescheuert.
Die stimmen nicht.
Du kannst...
Also zumindest früher konntest du da locker 40% von abziehen.
Also wenn...
Wenn...
Wenn da irgendwie drauf stand, das System kostet 20.000 Euro, dann hast du realistisch
dafür wahrscheinlich 12.000 Euro bezahlt.
Also da war wirklich jede...
Da hat auf den Webseiten jede Menge Mist gestanden.
Und...
Ansonsten...
Nee...
Das...
HP, Dell, IBM...
Das nimmt sich alles nicht so viel.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob die Sachen heute nicht sogar auch von Lenovo sind.
Ähm...
Was genau...
Was die...
Was die Server eigentlich...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob IBM überhaupt noch Server baut heutzutage.
Kann ich euch nicht sagen.
Ja, und zumindest mit der Zeit haben sie bei uns dann...
Hat irgendwie Dell ein bisschen den Fuß in die Tür bekommen.
Und mittlerweile ist es bei uns so, dass wir zum größten Teil Dell-Hardware haben.
Was hältst du von Supermicro für einen Heimbereich?
Das ist eine tolle Geschichte, was die haben.
Kann man nix sagen.
Im Enterprise-Umfeld habe ich es jetzt noch nicht so oft gesehen.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, als hätte ich quasi 20.000 Rechenzentrum-Bestandsaufnahme
bisher gemacht oder so.
Also Supermicro habe ich jetzt so, wenn überhaupt, nur wenig im Rechenzentrum irgendwo hängen
sehen.
Ähm...
Es ist zum größten Teil tatsächlich immer noch IBM, Lenovo, Dell und HP.
Zumindest da, wo ich es kenne, ja.
Dell EMC, das habe ich schon mal irgendwo gehört, ja.
Das kann schon durchaus Dell EMC sein.
Aber unsere Server sind von Dell, das weiß ich.
Vielleicht auch von Dell EMC.
Doch, das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Könnte tatsächlich sein.
Das steht, glaube ich, in diesem Tool, wo man die ganzen Serverdaten auslesen kann.
Wir haben irgend so ein Tool mit Webinterface, da kann man dann auslesen, ähm...
Keine Ahnung, ist eine RAM-Bank kaputt oder sowas.
Ich glaube, da steht was von Dell EMC.
Was hältst du von Thomas Gren?
Das Wiki ist gut.
Ansonsten kenne ich von denen nix.
Ne, iTrack ist das Remote...
Ne, ne, ne, ich meine nicht das iTrack.
iTrack ist ja das Remote-Management-Interface.
Es gibt so ein Tool von Dell, wo man alle seine Dell-Server damit verwalten kann.
Ähm...
Bei uns wird das immer nur das Dell-Tool genannt.
OpenManage, das genau.
Ja, genau, das meine ich.
Bei uns wird das immer nur das Dell-Tool genannt.
Aber OpenManage heißt der Krempel, glaube ich.
Ja, wirklich, hier, das da.
Ja, ja, genau, das da.
Ja, ich meine OpenManage, genau.
Hersteller machen gerne komische Dinger.
So, wir gucken jetzt das Video fertig.
Also, sein USV juckt mich nicht.
Last but not least is this rack.
This 18U rack is great.
When I bought it, my intention was to limit the amount of space...
Ähm...
Ein offenes Rack finde ich übrigens für daheim auch wirklich sinnvoll,
weil du hast ja keine Klimaanlage oder sowas.
Und du kommst auch einfacher mal dran.
Gerade wenn du es in so einer Ecke stehen hast.
Du hast halt in...
Du hast halt daheim keinen extra Raum mit einem Gang,
mit warmer und kalter Luft und mit Sachen dahinter.
Offenes Rack finde ich ist für daheim richtig gute Sache.
...that I have in my rack, so I won't be tempted to outgrow it.
I didn't think about the fact that it would be nice to have a few more slots,
just in case, for expansion.
Nervt das nicht mit Staub?
Naja, das kannst du eh nur umgehen, wenn du ein Rack hast,
was du wirklich auch immer zumachst vorne.
Und dann kommt da trotzdem Staub rein.
Also...
Für mich würd's das...
...aufwiegen.
Zumal ich das eh bei mir hier hinten in dem extra Raum habe.
Und da ist nicht viel Staub drinnen.
Und die Tür ist die ganze Zeit zu.
Also, in dem Raum ist kaum Staub.
Also, ich hab damit wenig Probleme mit Verstauben.
...even if it's for another system that's not running 24-7.
Guckt mal, dieser Server, den hier offen auf der Erde steht am Anfang...
Guckt mal, der Server, der hier offen auf der Erde steht am Anfang,
der war...
...vier Jahre oder so hier drinnen.
Seht ihr da großartig Staub?
Guckt mal, guckt mal.
Ein bisschen, ein BISSCHEN auf dem Noctua-Lüfter.
Ein BISSCHEN ist da.
Und ein BISSCHEN hier am Netzteil.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre da komplett eingestaubt.
Also...
...das hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Ja, aber Racks mit eingebauter Klimaanlage, das ist nix, was sich irgendjemand für daheim kauft.
Ich könnte eigentlich mal wieder ein Update bringen.
Die Sache ist bloß die...
...es gibt nicht so viel, was ich zeigen könnte, weil es hat sich kaum was getan.
Außer, dass da jetzt ein HP-Microserver steht noch drinnen.
Ja, und die Lampe steht da ja auch nicht drinnen.
Die ist einfach nur da, weil ich gedacht hab, es sieht cool aus im Video, wenn ich...
...selbstgebaute RGB-LED-Lampe zeige.
Gut, fertig, guckt mal.
Was will er denn da noch alles einbauen, Alter?
Das ist jetzt schon totaler Über-, äh, Over-, Overkill.
...und die Bauqualität.
Für mich würde ich sagen, dass das hier ein...
...upgradiert ist.
Damit ich mehr...
Also, ich hoffe...
...in der Homelab-Community, weil es...
...sono-schleife.
Es ist ganz einfach.
Wer das jetzt nicht kennt...
...wenn ihr Chrome schließt, ich mach das jetzt nicht, weil...
...dann mache ich euch hier aus und so...
...dann drückst Du Control-Shift-T, und dann ist...
...die alte Session wieder da.
Guck hier, letztes Tab wieder aufmachen.
Zack.
Control-Shift-T. Damit könnt ihr ganze Sessions wieder herstellen.
Pog. Shortcut.
So, was sind...was sind...
...die Essential Homelab Tools?
Weiß nicht, ob ich mir den Kerl noch mal...
Kabel!
Ja, Kabel sind tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Nein.
Krimpzange.
Kabeltester.
Wir gucken einfach hier unten durch, was wir da...
Okay.
Also, Kabeltester.
Ja.
Einen zu haben, das muss auch kein guter sein.
Einen zu haben, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Äh.
Switch.
Ja, schadet nix.
Ein paar Switches zu haben zum Testen.
Kabels, okay.
Ja, Kabels kann man nie genug brauchen.
Wisst ihr was?
Mir fällt es jedes Mal auf, der sieht immer so traurig aus.
Einfach nur dieser Ami-Stromstecker.
Äh, was ist das?
Praktisch.
Find ich gut.
Das, das hat was.
Das find ich cool.
Wie nennt sich sowas?
Leute, wie, wie, wie heißt das?
Wie heißt sowas?
Das find ich, das ist ne coole Sache.
Wie, wie, wie ist das?
All the normal things you would usually do
But pretty cheap
Volt, Voltpen oder so
Spannungsmesser
Sowas
Was hat der gesagt, Voltpen
Voltstick
Ein berührungsloser Spannungsprüfer
China-Chinesen-Krempel
Ne, please, was gescheites
Was hat der
Diese Fluke-Dinger oder Flugfilme
Die sind halt immer wahnsinnig teuer
Sowas da
Voltage-Tester 200 bis 100
Bis 1000
AC
Das ist ne
Also von der Idee her finde ich das eigentlich ziemlich praktisch
Wobei ich nix
Wobei ich es besser finden würde
Der geht noch und wird noch ein bisschen runter gehen
Egal, muss ich mir mal überlegen
Ob sowas sinnvoll ist
So, weiter
Was passiert bei 200 Volt
Nix
Achso, du meinst weil der bis 1000 ist
Vielleicht, weiß nicht
Vielleicht kackt der
Die LED-Trenner ab
Okay, aber das finde ich von der Idee her schon mal nice
... handy, when I was wiring up my server room
I should have bought this a long time ago
Now it's time to look at some more
Just a simple utility
Ein Cutter
Teppichmesser, auf gut Deutsch, ja
Das ist praktisch
Darf ich auch zwei Stück hier hinten hängen
Einmal eins in dieser Cutter-Form und dann so ein normales Teppichmesser
Teppichmesser kann man immer gebrauchen
... utility knife
With a retractable blade
So alles mögliche
Teppichmesser sind tatsächlich sehr praktisch
I just wanted to show you this pad, it works properly
Ganz so lang muss man es jetzt auch nicht zeigen
They're wondering like, wow, a screwdriver
Okay, da darf ich nichts zu sagen
Ich habe viel zu viel Geld ausgegeben für den Kram
Ich habe mir sogar, also
Was ich mega nice finde, was ich aber keinem empfehlen würde zu kaufen
Ich überlege gerade
Wo habe ich es denn
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich es hingeschmissen habe gerade
Wahrscheinlich ist es in der Werkzeughalter hinten
Ich habe mir einen Screwdriver mitgebracht
Swiss Tool
Boah, wie heißt dieses Ding
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht so ein Ding
Gekauft mit wechselbarem
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das Ding hieß
Ja, so ein Teil, genau
So was in der Richtung
Ne, Moment, länger
Der da, so was da in der Richtung
Ich hatte mir so ein Ding mal gekauft
Das ist wirklich vom Handling her
Wirklich mega nice, kannst du nicht sagen
Preislich komplett für den Arsch
Würde ich, sollte man, sollte man eigentlich nicht ausgeben
Ich meine, die wollen allen Ernstes
Für
Das geht ja sogar noch
Die wollen, also das ist teilweise wirklich, wirklich extrem teuer
Aber ich fand es nice
Es ist, also vom Handling her ist es nice
Die Ratsche ist wirklich super leichtläufig
Und fein, wie nennt man das so
Feinfühlig oder so
Ja, ist mittlerweile
Das ist wirklich mein Standardding mittlerweile
Wenn ich irgendwas mache
Wenn ich irgendwas zusammenbaue
Ich hab den Tisch für die
Feinzahnig, genau
Ich hab den Tisch für die Terrasse zusammengebaut
Die Liege für die Terrasse zusammengebaut
Wenn ich sonst irgendwas aufmachen muss
Wird das damit gemacht
Also ich nehm eigentlich
Wenn irgendwo was ist, wo ich mal gucken muss
Oder irgendwas basteln muss
Ich nehm eigentlich nix mit, außer dieses Ding
Zu 90% kommt man damit klar
Sehr praktisch
Aber unsinnig teuer
Ich hab mich da durch den Review-Video
Auf YouTube zu inspirieren lassen
Und ich hab mich da durch den Review-Video auf YouTube zu inspirieren lassen
Und ja, war eigentlich reichlich sinnlos
Aber okay
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch
Ein Dremel
Ja, so ein Teil hab ich auch
Das ist wirklich sehr praktisch
Wenn man's braucht
Ich brauch's selten, aber es ist praktisch
Zum Beispiel musste ich mal
Ihr werdet euch jetzt sicherlich fragen, wozu
Aber werde ich euch dann erzählen
Ähm, Wäscheständer
Ich musste mal Wäscheständer durchschneiden
Ich musste mal Metallstangen von Wäscheständern durchschneiden
Und da war ich wirklich froh
Dass ich diesen Dremel hatte
Mit den passenden Scheiben dran
Und
Normalerweise ist das nicht
Das, was ich oft machen muss, ja
Und mir ist aufgefallen
Dass es tatsächlich Funken gibt
Wenn man
Metall mit Metall
Durchschneidet
Ihr werdet jetzt sagen
Max, das weiß man doch
Das war mir zu dem Zeitpunkt aber nicht so gut
Das war mir aber nicht ganz klar
Dass es Funken gibt, wenn man mit Metall
Metall durchschneidet
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum man bei sowas
Normalerweise besser eine Schutzbrille aufzieht
Ja
Für solche Sachen
Enorm praktisch
Ich hab damit auch schon kleine Sachen
Ähm
Geklettet
Jetzt hab ich das Wort
Also mit so Schleifzeug
Oder poliert
Ähm
Oder durchgeschnitten
Oder durchgesägt
Also für so kleine Sachen ist das Ding
Universell wirklich äußerst praktisch
Man kann damit theoretisch auch bohren und schrauben
Was man aber nicht machen will
Dafür ist es nicht da
Ähm
Ja, aber gerade so Sachen
Wenn man mal sowas braucht
Ich mein, wie oft willst du Metallstäbe durchschneiden
Von einem Wäscheständer?
Eigentlich nie
Und gerade für so Sachen, die du eigentlich nie machst
Aber doch ab und zu mal machen musst
Ist so ein Universal-Tool praktisch
Weil damit kannst du vieles machen
Unter anderem halt mit dem passenden Aufsatz
Wäscheständer durchschneiden
Very specialized applications
Like for instance
Oh, this is kinda dirty
Es ist übrigens genau der gleiche, den ich auch hab
I had to modify my R710 to allow a video card to fit in it properly
And so I used this
Ja, kannst abschleifen
With the appropriate tip
File down the back of the PCI
Gehst du heute Abend aufs Museumsuferfest
Ich war am Freitag schon am Museumsuferfest
Und hab mir gedacht
Meine Güte, was hier am Wochenende los ist
Da lass ich mich bestimmt nicht blicken
Press on
And then I can plug in a 16X PCI Express card
A video card
Worked out pretty nice
And without this
I don't think it would have been possible
Moment, Moment, Moment
Was hat der ab?
Was hat der?
Der hat das hier abgesägt, oder was?
Without this, I don't think it would have been possible
I'd love to have more projects to use this
But again
Ja, für so kleine Sachen sind die Dinger wirklich praktisch
Also das ist ein super Universal-Tool
Für Sachen, die man normalerweise eigentlich nicht braucht
Aber man doch mal machen muss
Und du kannst halt alle möglichen Aufsätze draufmachen
Deswegen sind die echt praktisch
Also ich bin froh, dass ich mir auch so ein
Das ist genau der gleiche
Ich hab auch den 3000er, weil es der kleinste ist
Wirklich bin ich froh, dass ich mir das damals gekauft hab
This is a nice tool to have on hand
For very specialized things that you need to do
And it's another tool that's great to have
If a friend needs to borrow it
Start keeping tabs on that friend that needs to borrow all this stuff
Maybe you'll need something in return one day
That's not how it works
Fantastic
Now every now and then
I need to check the temperature of something
Whether that be a CPU
A heat sink
Some hard drives
Lass mich raten
Der hat so eine Infrarot-Wärme-Dings-Erkennungs-Teil jetzt
An open flame
Up until I had this device
It was kind of hard to do
And it's this digital thermometer
Ich hab mir das auch schon überlegt
Ich find die Dinger cool
Also cool ist vielleicht für was zum Wärme-
Ich find die Dinger
Das hat was
Aber ich hab mir da mal angeguckt was gute Geräte dafür kosten
Und dann dachte ich mir
Ne
So sehr will ich sowas auch nicht haben
You pointed at something
And it will tell you the temperature
Of the thing you're pointing it at
You can see this mat right here
Es gibt ja noch
Ne ne ne
Ich hab damals dann nach Dingern geguckt
Die so eine Wärme-Bildkamera noch drauf hatten
Wo man das was sieht
Die waren nicht günstig
Die waren von gutem Herzen
Also diese Dinger
Aber das was ich geguckt habe
Das hat was weiß ich
Das ging irgendwie ab 400 Euro los
Und da hab ich mir gedacht
Ne
Grease
If I point it at my Intel NUC that you can't see
It's about
Alter Fahrenheit
Geht das auch in einer ordentlichen Einheit
Well
Freedom
Not totally accurate
But 92 degrees
Oh it might be accurate
On the surface of my skin
But this is super handy
Hell yeah Fahrenheit
It's super fun
It's a nice party trick too
To point it at things
And figure out the temperature of things
It's pretty awesome
And relatively affordable too
Let's see what the temperature is
Nein ich will das auch nicht in Kelvin
Ich will das in Celsius
Weil ich damit besser was anfangen kann
Ich mein ganz im Ernst
Warum haben die Dinger kein Button
Da kann man einfach durch tappen
Celsius, Kelvin, Fahrenheit
Fahrenheit
Ist doch gut
Ich mein es ist jetzt nicht so
Als wäre das umrechnend wahnsinnig kompliziert
Ja ist praktisch
Aber ganz im Ernst
Wisst ihr was wirklich praktisch ist
Ich verwende
Ich hatte früher auch ein paar dieser Lampen
Die du dir auf den Kopf setzen kannst
Äh
Bosch
Was weiß ich
Licht
Weiß gar nicht was ich da suchen muss
12 Volt
Licht
Oder ne
Das Teil
Echt praktisch
Passen die gleichen Akkus
Wie von den Akkuschraubern
In den anderen 12 Volt Geräten rein
Du kannst es irgendwo hinhängen
Und es macht halt einfach hell
Es macht nicht so
Nicht so
Auf einen Punkt hell
Wie eine Tatsache
Eine Taschenlampe
Oder nen Kopflicht
Es macht aber halt einfach
Die gesamte Raumhälfte hell
Wo du was gucken musst
Seitdem ich das Ding hab benutze ich eigentlich
Im Keller oder sonst wo
Oder im Stall
Oder in der Garage
Immer wenn ich irgendwie da mal
Was gucken mache
Ich benutze nur noch das
Hinstellen
Du kannst es hinstellen
Du kannst es
Du kannst es ähm
Hinlegen
Du kannst es irgendwo dran machen
Äh magnetisch ist es
Glaub
Ist ne gute Frage
Ich glaube magnetisch ist es nicht
Ne ich glaub magnetisch ist es nicht
So gut weiß ich gar nicht
Glaub wenn ich ausbeute
Ich glaube es ist nicht magnetisch
Also
Zum Beispiel in dem Keller
Hänge ich das an die Decke
An irgendein Kabel
Und ich seh alles
Wunderbar
Also
Ich benutze keine Kopflichter mehr
Ich benutze keine Taschenlampen mehr
Seitdem ich das Ding hab
Zumal es mit dem gleichen 12 Volt Akku
Für die Akkuschrauber
Und äh
Den Bohrer
Ne nicht den
Den
Das ist kein Bohrer
Ja der kann bohren
Aber ist immer der Akkuschrauber
Und äh
Den Bohrer
Ne nicht den
Den
Das ist kein Bohrer
Aber ist immer der Akkuschrauber
Äh
Geht
Äußerst praktische Sache
Früher hatte ich auch viele solche Kopflichter
Ja okay
Da hast du die Hand frei
Aber bei dem anderen hast du auch die Hand frei
Weil das einfach
Neben dich stellen kann
Random Frage
Hattest du in letzter Zeit nochmal in WW3 reingeschaut?
Nein
Ja
Mir weil sich indes RealsCH главное
Ich meine
Ich weiß immer noch nicht was mit den Map
Designern dort los war
Warum die allen Ernstes in Berlin das Arbeitsamt auf einem Map gepackt
Haben aber okay
Was teilt auf
Wirklich
Hallo Leute hier ist der Max
Ag98
Kansas
Wir arbeiten
Sind
Durch Berlin gelaufen haben einfach mal fotos gemacht von allen möglichen
Mit
Ab נ美國
Weiter
dinge an die da rum hängt oder was warum ist das arbeitsamt auf der map drauf wer
kennt nicht die schlacht am arbeitsamt wahrscheinlich wussten die einfach gar
nicht was er da fotografiert haben
macht am dienstag einen battlefield 2042 stream kann durchaus sein
neue season gucken wir uns an ist doch realistisch ich weiß nicht ob die beste
ecke in berlin ist das wo die für eine map wo das arbeitsamt ist da der recht
die amis nennen das ja immer velcro wahrscheinlich weil der hersteller da
super bekannt ist ich meine die sagen ja auch xerox für kopieren und solche
sachen so wie wir tempo sagen für taschentücher oder nutella oder was es
dann ist sonst nicht noch alles gibt die dinger sind wirklich praktisch also
klettverschlüsse beziehungsweise diese
hüftschlüsse sind wirklich praktisch also klettverschlüsse beziehungsweise diese
hybrid dinge aus kleber aus seite die klebt und klettverschluss die sind
tatsächlich echt praktisch
managing cables but if you want something a little more permanent
also ich mag bei diesen dingern zum
also ich mag bei diesen dingern zum befestigen von geräten es gibt welche
befestigen von geräten es gibt welche
befestigen von geräten es gibt welche die haben auf der einen seite kleber und
die haben auf der einen seite kleber und
die haben auf der einen seite kleber und auf der anderen seite haben die für
auf der anderen seite haben die für
Klettband-Seite.
Also da kannst du auf der einen Seite
das dran kleben, auf der anderen Seite hast du
eine Halterung für so einen Klettverschluss.
Und dann kannst du dann auf das, machst du
an das Gerät, machst du das auf der einen Seite
und beispielsweise, ja,
keine Ahnung,
an den Kühlschrank machst du die andere
Seite und dann kannst du die Dinger miteinander
verbinden, quasi
musst du sie nicht aufeinander
kleben, sondern kannst
sie ineinander kletten.
Ja gut, Kabelbinder haben wir glaube ich
alle da. Rack, Mounting,
Muttern und Schrauben.
Ja, braucht man.
Was auch immer das sein soll.
Irgendwelche Abstandshalter.
Achso,
ich erkenne nichts. Alter, ich sehe
nichts.
Was?
Ach.
Ja, braucht keiner.
Also wenn das die Schiene
hat, dann ist das ein Problem.
Wenn das ein China-Chinesen-Kram ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Na gut, okay.
War jetzt nicht so viel Spannendes dabei.
Keck, wait.
Wir wurden betrogen.
Da hat
ich aufgepasst.
Der Auer zeigt uns ein
flexibles 45 Zoll
OLED-Display mit 240
Hertz. Ja, coole Technik, aber
bestimmt am Ende so unglaublich teuer,
dass selbst ich mir diesen Krempel nicht
kaufen würde. Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Ich bin dreieinhalb Stunden...
Und ich bin geneigt
dazu, jetzt aufzugehen
und was zu fordern.
Oh.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, ihr seid wach.
Ja, es gibt andere, die streamen jeden Tag
sieben Stunden ohne Probleme, ich weiß.
Aber ich bin ja auch schon Boomer.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie der
Losters teilweise sieben Stunden am Stück durchhält.
Oder andere Streamer.
Keine Ahnung.
Sogar den Krieger
habe ich teilweise irgendwie zehn Stunden
plus da rumhocken sehen, wo ich mir denke,
wie macht ihr das denn so lang?
Na gut, man muss sagen, ich glaube,
viele Streamer,
die schwätzen auch nicht so viel
wie ich, oder? Die spielen irgendwas,
geben da Kommentare zu, aber ich bin
ja quasi dreieinhalb Stunden, ich hole
ja quasi nie Luft, ich labere ja
eigentlich dreieinhalb Stunden durch.
Michael, fünf Spilljahren, auch mal
wieder am Start. Massive Subscription,
da ist er.
Dankeschön, 25 Monate.
Henrius,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, und die machen das Vollzeit, natürlich,
die müssen das machen, aber trotzdem.
Also ob du...
Deswegen wird es ja nicht weniger anstrengend.
Ich frage mich halt immer nur, wie die Leute das durchhalten.
Wenn ich das...
Ich würde das auch machen, wenn ich...
Also nicht Vollzeit, aber ich...
Für mich sind dreieinhalb Stunden schon
anstrengend genug.
Ich hätte gar keinen Bock, sieben Stunden zu streamen.
Echt cooler Stream und inhaltlich
sehr interessant. Ja, schön, dass dir das gefallen hat.
Wir haben uns ja heute eigentlich hauptsächlich mit fremden
Federn geschmückt und uns Videos angeguckt
von anderen Leuten.
Aber ansonsten, wir können nicht immer
High-IQ-Content selbst produzieren.
So.
Schauen wir mal.
30 Milliarden, danke schön für die Bits.
Massive.
Hast du dir mal Teleport angeschaut?
Nein. Gut.
Dann werde ich jetzt abhauen.
69% Leute.
69% für den
Hype Train.
Ich wollte aber gerade
off gehen.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Schön, dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Wir müssen echt auch mal unseren
Rust-Ausflug weitermachen.
Und spätestens, wenn ich mein Auto habe
und die Wallbox und so, müssen wir da auf jeden Fall
einiges basteln.
Alles klar, bis denn. Macht's gut, CU.